Emmanuel Macron et Joe Biden s'étaient
il y a quelques minutes des images que
nous avons pas pu suivre en direct
puisque et bien l'Élysée la Maison
Blanche nous les ont retransmis en léger
différé vous les avez vu discuter au
coin du feu dans le bureau Val de la
Maison Blanche
17h30 de nous sommes en direct
oserais-je dire que c'est un moment
historique peut-être le président de la
République française
ici des honneurs d'une visite d'État à
Washington Joe Biden a réservé sa
première visite d'État à Emmanuel Macron
vous avez suivi l'arrivée tout à l'heure
très cérémonieuse du président français
à la Maison Blanche et depuis binden et
Macron centre tienne discute dans le
Bureau Vallée des deux hommes seront
face à la presse pour rendre compte de
cet échange cela devait commencer il y a
quelques minutes et bien ils sont en
retard mais on va pour cela et bien
attendre et je suis avec Renaud Girard
bonjour Renaud grand reporter
chroniqueur international au Figaro
merci d'être ici je m'emballe quand je
parle de moments historiques c'est rare
une telle visite quand même
oui alors ce n'est pas les visites de
présidents français aux États-Unis le
président américain en France
sont quand même des choses qui
reviennent au cours des années alors
visite d'État c'est tout le cérémoniales
je pense que c'est la compensation pour
la mauvaise manière que les Américains
avaient fait lors de l'histoire des
sous-marins avec souvenez que
Emmanuel Macron avait appris par la
presse
que
les Alliés c'est-à-dire ces alliés
anglais américains et australien
derrière son dos
avait
flingué le contrat qui était pourtant
c'est pas rien signé 56 milliards
d'euros 12 sous-marins voilà des 12
sous-marins français conçus par naval BO
groupe pour les australien pour le
remplacer par des sous-marins nucléaires
d'attaques de construction américaine
mais Emmanuel Macron ne l'avait appris
que pas la presse et déjà la prendre par
la même en direct c'était déjà une
mauvaise manière mais par la presse
c'était pire voilà et en fait vous
souvenez à cette époque c'était donc
on parle là de septembre 2021
la France avait même rappelé son
ambassadeur à Washington pendant 8 jours
je crois que ça s'était jamais fait dans
l'histoire diplomatique des deux pays et
Biden donc c'est pas vraiment excusé
mais enfin bon ils ont et donc là c'est
vraiment la compensation d'accord pour
cette humiliation qui avait été fait au
président de la République française par
un travail finalement la mairie la
France ont les deux plus vieux alliés de
l'histoire contemporaine puisque l'aide
de la France à l'Amérique remonte à
1780 la guerre d'indépendance américaine
et que les deux pays ne se sont jamais
fait la guerre je saluer le Rico qui
nous dit il a dit revenons redevenons
frères d'armes oui c'était tout à
l'heure vous voyez l'arrivée d'Emmanuel
Macron c'était aux alentours de 14h30
heure française il a pris la parole et
il a dit à Joe Biden redevenons frères
d'armes ça veut dire quoi on ne l'était
plus depuis quelques années quelques
mois et bien
redevenons frères sais pas si vous
voulez effectivement il y a eu ce
traumatisme de effectivement
si vous êtes frères d'armes normalement
vous ne faites pas des coups en 12
d'ailleurs leur dos derrière le dos de
votre frère et donc faisait surtout
aussi les Australiens qui a fait un
doute bien poussé par les Américains
2 sur 3 ont été depuis
viré par leurs peuple l'Australien et
l'anglais ont été virés mais Biden
reste ce sont pas Biden qui était
vraiment venez d'arriver lui venait
d'arriver et
et donc par ailleurs c'était pas du tout
anormal que pour faire face à la Chine
les
Australiens c'est qu'ils passent de
sous-marin nucléaire d'attaque parce que
ce qui devait acheter aux français
c'était des sous-marins classiques et
les espaces sont tellement grands dans
le Pacifique effectivement ça pue
beaucoup de sens mais ils auraient pu
aussi bien demander
l'autorisation française de leur acheter
des sous-marins nucléaires d'attaque
français puisque on sait les faire
il y en a la nouvelle série vient de
sortir il s'appelle Barracuda mais bon
alors il est évident aussi qu'il faut
pas rêver que face à la Chine évidemment
que c'est l'Amérique qui protège
l'Australie qui protège tous les pays de
la région
Asie-Pacifique c'est-à-dire les Alliés
la Corée du Sud le Japon l'Australie etc
que la France peut pas prétendre jouer
elle veut elle veut jouer à certains
rôles en Asie elle peut pas prétendre de
jouer le jeu du grand protecteur
mais voilà donc Renaud je rappelle que
nous attendons la conférence de presse
commune entre Joe Biden et Emmanuel
Macron et se sont entretenus tout
l'après-midi à la Maison Blanche vous
voyez ces images en direct ce sont des
images de Gilles et Gilles Biden et
Brigitte Macron elles sont à Washington
elle visite un musée pendant que leur
mari eux s'entretenaient dans le dans le
bureau ovale nous aurons évidemment les
images dans quelques instants des
pupitres ou les deux présidents
s'exprimeront on attend beaucoup parce
que nous verrons si les problèmes sont
réglés notamment sur cette question des
des sous-marins alors qu'on va donc les
deux femmes des présidents qui
s'entraînaient avec des de jeunes gens
visiblement on écoutera peut-être un peu
tout à l'heure ce qui est
Emmanuel Macron
avait dit
c'était après l'abandon des cures de
progressistes par américain qui avait
même pas prévenu qu'il partait leurs
alliés britanniques et français on parle
des cures qui sont dans la bande à au
nord de la Syrie
Emmanuel Macron avec commentaire en
disant que le temps était cérébralement
mort et évidemment la guerre d'Ukraine a
ressoudé totalement ressuscité le temps
et donc
ressouder les liens puisque
les Français sont du côté des Américains
qui sont du côté des Ukrainiens et donc
les Français évidemment livre beaucoup
moins d'armes que non livre les mêmes
mais les Français livrent quand même des
armes modernes notamment César donc on
parle beaucoup les fameux canon César
qui ont fait leur qui ont montré leur
valeur dans cette guerre qui était déjà
beaucoup une guerre artillerie et qui va
leur rester encore plus
maintenant que les positions l'hiver
sont un peu gelées
de part et d'autre d'une nièpre au sud
de l'Ukraine et même au Dombas sur les
anciennes sur les anciens réseaux
fortifiés de la guerre de 2014 et bien
c'est vraiment l'artillerie va jouer un
grand rôle et donc là lesquels on
français vont être très utiles alors
l'effort français est important à
l'égard de l'Ukraine il est évidemment
sans commune mesure avec
l'effort militaire américain en faveur
de l'Ukraine qui on peut le dire
l'effort le plus important qui était
consenti par l'Amérique depuis la loi de
pré-bail accordée à l'Angleterre en
1941 Renaud je lis ce que nous disent
nos internautes Momo tiens qui nous dit
laquelle les deux est la plus jeune
question étonnante alors je vais vous le
dire c'est Brigitte Macron qui a 69 ans
et j'ai le baiden à 71
92 les Américains ne font pas de
sentimentalisme la réaction d'Emmanuel
Macron sur les frères d'armes sera sans
effet est-ce que c'est vrai Renault
est-ce que finalement d'accord on essaye
de soigner les égaux on reçoit Emmanuel
Macron grande pompe mais est-ce que les
Américains ont vraiment envie de
travailler à nouveau avec les Français
sur plein de points pas que sur les
sous-marins parce qu'il y a plein de
sujets alors je crois qu'ils sont
attachés à l'alliance avec l'Europe je
crois que ils sont conscients du fait
qu'il y a quand même une vieille
alliance avec la France ça c'est très
clair il ne respecte plus la France
comme il l'a respecté autrefois
certainement moins que du temps du
général de Gaulle
puisque maintenant pour eux le pays le
plus important en Europe c'est
l'Allemagne
ah oui oui tout à fait même des
alors c'est le plus il y a des
déclarations américaines qui disent que
le leader de l'Europe c'est l'Allemagne
alors aujourd'hui le leader en terme de
personnalité je veux dire Emmanuel
Macron est plus charismatique
semble-t-il que la scholls depuis le
départ dans alors est-ce que alors
est-ce que c'est vrai d'abord
c'est vrai que soit ne l'est pas du tout
est-ce que les américains
s'intéressent vraiment Emmanuel Macron
on va peut-être le voir dans des
réactions différentes dans les
différents articles et commentaires qui
nous viendront de des Etats-Unis et
notamment de notre correspondant là-bas
Adrien jaune ce que je peux dire c'est
que
les États-Unis c'est un porte-avion et
que ce porte-avions qui voilà qui très
important qui suit son siège et les
Français n'ont jamais
réussi
à faire changer la politique américaine
de stratégie vous souvenez que Dominique
de Villepin avait condamné avait averti
solennellement les Américains de ne pas
envahir l'Irak en 2003
avec un discours très célèbre en février
2003 à l'ONU et les Américains avaient
fait quand même l'histoire pourtant a
donné 100% raison à Dominique 2001 mais
les Américains n'ont pas suivi des
conseils le seul foie ou la France a
vraiment pu un peu orienté la politique
américaine c'est lorsque nous avons été
à la fois
alliés mais pas un petit pas un petit
chat c'est à dire à la fois critique
c'est à dire allié mais pas aligné
c'était du temps du général de Gaulle ou
à la fois la France a été extrêmement
solidaire des États-Unis lors des deux
crises de Berlin de 1950
Emmanuel Macron veulent un dialogue
exigeant parce de la France n'est pas un
allié aligné bon voilà alors très bien
et
et de Gaulle avait donc montré aussi de
solidarité avec les Américains
immédiatement sur la crise des missiles
à Cuba c'est-à-dire à l'époque c'était
les Américains qui ne supportaient pas
des missiles russes à Cuba peut se poser
la question aujourd'hui est-ce que il
faudrait que les Russes supportent des
missiles américains en Ukraine c'est une
autre question mais en tout cas à
l'époque il est certain que les
Américains ne supportaient pas la
présence de missiles russes à Cuba qui
était pourtant il y a dépendants et de
Gaulle avait montré de la solidarité
mais par ailleurs ensuite il avait
critiqué l'Amérique sur le Vietnam sur
le privilège exorbitant du dollar qui
est resté d'ailleurs
nous avions quitté l'organisation
intégrée de l'OTAN tout en restant
évidemment dans l'Alliance atlantique et
mais en fait ce discours de
l'indépendance de Gaulle qui disait
aussi de la détente et bien avait porté
ses fruits puisqu'il était respecté par
les Américains et Nixon à peine élu
président
va rendre visite au général de Gaulle
c'était fin janvier
1969 et là il dira à de Gaulle à la
France en fait vous jouez dans la même
catégorie que nous et là de Gaulle
c'était permis de lui donner un conseil
qui était de reconnaître à la Chine
populaire ce que Nixon fera quelques
années plus tard donc là à cette époque
là et là ça remonte
depuis je ne pense pas que la France la
France ait pu vraiment influencer les
États-Unis elles ont l'air complice
Gilles Biden et Brigitte Macron nous
attendons leur mari qui doivent
s'exprimer lors d'une conférence de
presse commune ils s'entretiennent
toujours visiblement alors c'est entre
ce sont peut-être entretenus maintenant
chacun rédige avec son équipe les
éléments de langage qui seront donnés en
quelques instants
le journaliste allez je vous propose
qu'on écoute peut-être ce qui se passe
dans ce musée où j'ai le Biden et
Brigitte Macron
semble tenir une sorte de conférence
avec des de jeunes gens allez on écoute
un instant et puis on revient ici en
direct en attendant Emmanuel Macron et
Joe Biden
[Musique]
[Rires]
je voulais savoir quand c'est professeur
quel sujet est-ce que vous enseignez ou
pas
rappelle-moi ta question
[Rires]
même si j'ai senti que les choses
allaient arriver le jour où ça arrive
c'est une charge très importante c'est
un honneur c'est d'abord un honneur et
après
on a envie d'être là et de et d'aider au
mieux c'est comme ça que je pense être
là à côté de
et aider tout ce qui nous le demandent
au mieux et c'est pas facile parce que
les demandes sont très très importantes
et donc on fait des déçus
le matin
alors après mes chaussures
mes vêtements c'est un styliste qui
s'appelle Nicolas Gesquière qui
travaille
pour travail qui connaît parfaitement et
qui connaît mes pieds mes épaules tout
donc il dessine et c'est plus facile
je pense à Nicolas gesquierté
[Musique]
alors on n'a pas tout entendu pour tout
vous dire non vous avez mieux entendu
que nous mais elles ont l'air assez
complices dites nous vous si vous avez
mieux entendu vous réagissez sur le
Figaro.fr bon évidemment ce qu'on attend
et sur Youtube puisque nous sommes sur
Youtube ce qu'on attend c'est évidemment
la conférence de presse commune entre
jobiden et Emmanuel Macron ils ne sont
pas arrivés pour l'instant comment ça se
passe d'ailleurs on s'entretient on
discute et après j'imagine qu'on va voir
son équipe pour savoir quand retenir
les positions ont été préparées par
l'ambassade de France à originale vous
savez il y a une ambassade c'est la plus
grande ambassade de France à l'étranger
donc les diplomates ont
déjà si vous voulez beaucoup pour
discuter sur les avancées possibles il y
a quelque chose sur laquelle je pense
que Emmanuel Macron aimerait bien faire
changer de cap le porte-avion parce que
j'ai comparé la politique américaine au
siège d'un porte-avion c'est sûr ce
qu'on appelle ira veut dire
l'anti-flation actes
de subvention
très importante qui ont été votées
à l'industrie américaine
pour que l'industrie américaine ne soit
pas pénalisée par les prix d'énergie et
c'est une loi en fait qui est
protectionniste bien sûr et donc ça va
complètement fausser la concurrence
puisque les entreprises américaines
manufacturières vont payer leur énergie
peut-être quatre fois moins cher ou
trois fois moins cher que les industries
manufacturières françaises et européenne
en général et donc il y a cet avis qu'on
il faut absolument faire changer les
États-Unis de cap mais c'est une loi qui
a été votée par le Congrès je vois pas
le bonheur
et
c'est très louable c'est des efforts
très lois de la Emmanuel Macron ça
m'étonnerait énormément qu'il arrive à
faire bouger d'un iota
la politique américaine mais j'imagine
que on va lui poser des questions les
journalistes vont lui poser des
questions là-dessus et qui va répondre
alors c'est vrai ce sont les grands
sujets on va tous les aborder évidemment
en attendant les deux chefs d'État il y
avait la question des fameux sous-marins
donc on en a parlé déjà un peu ce fameux
une fashion réduction actes
veut essayer de trouver une parade veut
essayer de convaincre Joe Biden de
changer d'avis mais qu'il n'y arrivera
pas et que finalement il veut simplement
prendre une sorte de tirer des
conclusions pour pouvoir faire la même
chose en Europe est-ce que c'est
possible
alors effectivement ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que il aura averti des Américains
américains n'auront rien fait et là on
peut dire qu'il y aura un bail européen
actes les Européens feront une sorte de
loi européenne pour acheter européen ou
des mesures je dirais
de oui de représailles c'est un gros un
mot enfin des mesures qui répondent aux
propres mesures américaines alors c'est
sûr que en matière commerciale et les
c'est ce qu'on fait de l'histoire les
Américains ne comprennent que les
rapports de force et donc
souvent il y avait une c'était est-ce
que nous on est capable de l'imposer le
rapport de force la France et l'Europe
le rapport de force surtout l'Europe
avait été capable moi je vais vous
donner un exemple allez-y un moment la
BNP a été sanctionnée par la justice
américaine
pour avoir financé en dollars des
exportations
de pétrole iranien soudanais et de
cigarques Cuba alors il y a un embarque
américain sur ces trois pays mais pas un
embargo européen ni français donc en
fait la BNP n'avait contrevenu à aucune
loi européenne mais il y a ce qu'on
appelle l'extraterritorialité du droit
américain donc les procureurs Américains
disent ah mais vous avez utilisé cela et
donc ça c'était conclu par parce qu'ils
avaient très peur d'être condamnés à BNP
une amende de la bagatelle de 9
milliards de dollars qui avaient dû
payer la BNP à
donc au Trésor américain et alors
Hollande a essayé de le président
Hollande avait essayé de faire quelque
chose pour la BNP on n'avait pas la
obamajoro là là je peux rien faire c'est
la justice et oui ben c'est vrai que
quand on peut se mettre 9 milliards dans
la poche ah bah on peut rien faire alors
qu'est-ce qu'on aurait dû faire
qu'est-ce que j'aurais été qu'est-ce que
j'aurais fait oui oui des Affaires
étrangères on présente la République en
tout cas si j'avais été président de la
Commission européenne
contrairement aux je crois au
luxembourgeois qui était à cette époque
un peu aplati devant les États-Unis qui
était tout à l'époque président du la
Commission européenne ben moi j'aurais
j'aurais convoqué la banque Goldman
Sachs c'est la fameuse
affaire en 2007-2008 hors de la crise
des subprimes voilà et même oui d'abord
et même avant je l'aurais convoqué
son patron son son type exécutif
officiel j'ai cher ami j'ai un petit
souci parce que il est avéré que vous
avez aidé la graisse à maquiller ses
comptes publics afin d'intégrer la zone
euro parce que Goldman Sachs avait été
le officiel de la rue du gouvernement
grec reconnaissait cher ami que c'est
quand même une fraude considérable
une petite amende de 20 milliards de
dollars si vous refusez la payer cela
n'a aucune importance cher ami mais
évidemment vous serez interdit
d'exercices sur le territoire de l'Union
Européenne vous avez ainsi que toutes
les banques correspondantes
ce sont des alliés Emmanuel Macron la
réplée tout à l'heure il nous faut
savoir redevenir frère d'armes mais vous
me dites
en matière commerciale à l'égard des
États-Unis il n'y a qu'une chose qu'il
comprennent c'est le rapport de force
mais je ne suis pas sûr que les beaucoup
de pays de l'Union européenne sont prêts
à ce rapport de force je suis pas sûr je
suis sûr que les pays de l'Est les bases
les Polonais etc sont opposés à tout
rapport de force à l'égard aux
États-Unis et je suis même pas sûr que
les Allemands sont prêts à faire un
rapport de force Renault avec des
Américains nous nous approchons
gentiment de 18 heures 17h55 vous voyez
les images c'est tout à l'heure en début
d'après-midi ce matin américaines de
Baden et Macron qui se sont entretenus
ensuite dans le bureau Val au coin du
feu vous les voyez ici nous attendons
maintenant la déclaration commune ils
doivent se présenter à la à la presse
devant la presse et puis nous aurons
peut-être enfin des réponses et vous
avez vu des images en direct de Jill
Biden et Brigitte Macron dans un musée
alors là la caméra se perd devant le
musée mais c'est intéressant Renault
vous me disiez
Washington c'est la ville des musées oui
c'est la alors Washington c'est la
capitale
fédérale américaine mais au départ il y
avait rien donc c'est pas une très
grande ville par rapport aux autres
grandes villes américaines par rapport à
New York Boston Chicago etc
Nouvelle-Orléans des villes historiques
et
Washington a été mis là parce que
c'était entre le les États du Nord et
les États du Sud qui formaient les 13
colonies américaines du départ et
mais il y a quand même toute la dépense
fédérale et le prestige de la capitale
des États-Unis et donc vous avez eu
successivement les grands musées sont
venus s'établir sur sur la grande avenue
centrale de chaque côté et donc si vous
allez à Washington c'est vraiment un
bonheur pour les musées parce que vous
avez des meilleurs musées d'Arles le
musée de le musée aussi de l'espace
grand reporter chroniqueur international
et guide touristique également il faut
faire la liste des musées à visiter à
Washington tiens vous venez de me parler
du spatial on a
évoqué les sujets de discussion
potentiel entre jobiden et manuel Macron
on a parlé donc de cette crise des
sous-marins c'était l'année dernière
cette crise est-elle réglée on a parlé
du protectionnisme américain Emmanuel
Macron saura-t-il faire plier Joe Biden
Renault nous dit qu'il a peu d'espoir
alors une partie sur le spatial aussi
pour la faire simple est-ce que Macron
est en train de négocier pour envoyer
Thomas Pesquet sur la lune alors d'abord
vous avez demandé est-ce que c'est réglé
les Zuma oui c'est réglé c'est-à-dire
que les
il y a eu une discussion d'homahome
entre le Premier ministre australien et
Emmanuel Macron le Premier ministre
australien ayant changé entre-temps
c'est pas Scott Morrison qui a
d'ailleurs des ennuis
ça lui a pas porté chance d'avoir fait
des enduits à la France il a des ennuis
chez lui sur d'autres dossiers en ce
moment
mais le nouveau à la Benaise nouveau
Premier ministre australien c'est
réconcilié avec la France le groupe
naval Group a obtenu je crois une bonne
un bon dédommagement de 500 millions de
d'euros 500 millions sur une vente à 56
milliards
mais tout le travail beaucoup du travail
était quand même fait en Australie
d'accord en fait naval group se porte
bien n'a pas fait une si mauvaise
affaire à d'autres beaucoup d'autres
commandes à honorer et les Australiens
bon ne verront en fait sans doute pas de
mal à veille leur sous-marin nucléaire
d'attaque
bon mais c'est un dossier maintenant
passé mais c'est ce qui était choquant
c'est pas que les Australiens changent
d'avis parce que finalement on peut
toujours changer d'avis sur une
stratégie c'est vrai que ça ça ne
faisait pas grand-chose d'avoir des
sous-marins classiques par rapport à des
sous-marins nucléaires renégocier
surtout l'avertir à l'avant bien sûr que
mais que Macron puisse avoir préparé
l'opinion publique française là c'était
extrêmement vexant il a il a il a montré
qu'il était rien pour ses alliés quoi je
sens que vous voulez pas parler du
spatial vous le pose une vidéo je vous
pose une dernière question
une dernière question sur cette crise
des sous-marins parce que on a beaucoup
parlé des sous-marins c'est vrai que ça
c'est la partie visible de l'iceberg
finalement mais ce que ce qui est agacé
man Macron c'est qu'il y a eu la
création de Locus c'est l'Australie et
les États-Unis et les Anglais pour
contrer l'expression l'expansion
chinoise en Indo-Pacifique c'est ça
c'est-à-dire que en fait il faut savoir
que c'est puissant était allié
évidemment depuis la Deuxième Guerre
mondiale c'est en fait l'Amérique qui a
assuré la protection de l'Australie
parce que l'Angleterre était très
affaibli et contre le Japon puisqu'elle
avait perdu Singapour c'est l'Amérique
qui est venu protéger l'Australie en
la bataille de la mère de corail et donc
la protection de l'Australie c'est
l'Amérique bon voilà et c'est
puissance les Australiens nous nous
sommes reconnaissants à l'égard des
Australiens parce qu'ils sont venus
lors de la première guerre mondiale se
battre pour nous alors qu'ils étaient
loin donc nous sommes des alliés
évidemment des des Australiens mais ces
anglo-saxons qu'on appelle les pays de
Five eyes c'est-à-dire que il s'échange
tous les
mais c'est une alliance qui date de
ces années-là 42 il y a donc la mairie
l'Angleterre le Canada
l'Australie et la Nouvelle-Zélande
tous les renseignements et c'est
vraiment des alliés durs comme faire
donc aocus
change dans la mesure où c'est où ça ça
remet à la mode si vous voulez cette
alliance mais qui n'avait jamais été
connu
parce que c'était la première fois que
les puissances nucléaires
donnaient du matériel nucléaire à une
puissance non nucléaire ça se faisait
pas avant et c'est la première fois que
donc les Américains et les Anglais ont
donné
se sont engagés à donner du matériel
nucléaire une puissance qu'il était pas
qui était l'Australie mais la France
aurait pu demander aurait pu faire la
même chose mais bon voilà mais ça si
vous voulez ça fait ça fait du sens il
était extraordinaire que ce soit la
France qui est gagnée ce contrat des
sous-marins bon mais mais
c'est la manière c'est la manière était
très humiliant pour Macron l'espace
l'espace je précise parce que vous me
faites des tunnels Renaud Gérard mais
ceux qui nous rejoignent il faut que je
les je leur explique ce qu'on attend on
attend Emmanuel Macron et Joe Biden qui
doivent prendre la parole ils doivent
tenir une conférence de presse commune
nous verrons s'il répond à toutes ces
questions qu'on se pose depuis
maintenant une demi-heure il devrait il
devait parler aux alentours de 17h30 il
est 18h02 et il est deux hommes ne sont
toujours pas là c'est pour ça qu'il faut
emprunter des tunnels en attendant mais
moi je vous propose plutôt plutôt que de
m'enterrer de m'élever vers l'espace et
je vous repose donc cette question cher
Renault est-ce que Emmanuel Macron est
en train de négocier
le départ de Thomas Pesquet pour la lune
alors je crois que ça ferait plaisir je
crois qu'il y a d'autres parce qu'on est
là pour faire plaisir non non mais je
crois que ce soit un symbole
effectivement mais
de la coopération et les Français ont un
centre d'études spéciales mais il y a
aussi tout de quoi toute la coopération
qui peut être faite entre les deux
alliés donc américain et le français
sur sur
la militarisation de l'espace est
interdite par un traité par le traité de
Washington justement mais
sur les mesures qu'on peut prendre quand
même pour éviter qu'un adversaire qui
respecterait pas le traité de Washington
pour se prémunir de ces attaques dans
l'espace pour l'améliorer aussi
l'amélioration des des communications
dans l'espace et aussi évidemment de
l'espionnage à partir de l'espace donc
l'espace est devenu
une aire de confrontation sans qu'on le
dise parce que ça allait depuis déjà un
moment mais sans qu'on normalement à
traiter international dont les Russes et
les chinois sont signataires qui
interdit mais il y a quand même oui on a
bien compris que c'est un enjeu
extrêmement important
notamment dans l'enseignement alors le
symbole de savoir s'il va y avoir un
astronaute français ou pas bon on
explique parce que théoriquement les
Américains veulent envoyer leur fameuse
mission Artemis sur la Lune en 2025 et
il pourrait y avoir un Européen et
la star finalement européenne des
spationautes c'est Thomas Pesquier donc
si l'Europe et la France réussit à
négocier
un ticket finalement pour l'espace ce
serait probablement pour Thomas Pesquet
voilà et ce serait un beau symbole car
français marche sur la lune quand même
le premier
ça serait un beau symbole mais moi je
vais vous dire je connais bien les
Américains puisque j'ai fait de nombreux
séjours aux États-Unis pour Le Figaro
la les Américains sont des gens
pragmatiques et donc ce qu'ils vont
apprécier chez Thomas Pesquet c'est son
expérience d'astronaute le fait qu'il
est déjà fait ses preuves ça pour eux
c'est très important et donc c'est pas
ça pour faire un cadeau Emmanuel Macron
si Thomas Pesquet est bon d'accord très
important pour moi ils prennent pas de
risque et
dans la dans la mentalité américaine le
type qui a fait ses preuves ben c'est
très important pour eux
c'est le stationnement européen qui a
passé le plus de temps en l'espace et
bien je pense que c'est un argument qui
plaidera encore davantage que toutes les
demandes que pourrait faire Emmanuel
Macron mais sachez Thomas Pesquet en
plus et du déplacement il est à
Washington avec le chef de l'État en ce
moment donc sans doute des raisons mais
c'est parce que il a cette expérience
qui est très valorisée par les
Américains allez autre sujet qui
pourrait être abordé tout à l'heure qui
devrait être abordé oui je pense que on
peut en être sûr c'est l'Ukraine
évidemment alors est-ce que
on peut se réajuster ou finalement tout
roule entre les Etats-Unis et la France
sur l'aide à l'Ukraine on est d'accord
vous avez dit tout à l'heure que cette
guerre d'une certaine manière avait
ressuscité l'OTAN est-ce que sur la
stratégie en Ukraine américain et
français sont d'accord ou est-ce qu'il
faut encore discuter je dirais que ils
sont d'accord d'autant plus que les
Américains sont revenus un peu en
arrière s'il y avait eu le discours de
Varsovie de baiden ou non seulement bien
sûr il s'agissait
d'aider financièrement et militairement
les
Ukrainiens leur envoyant des équipements
mais
où Joe Biden avait appelé dans son
discours de Varsovie un changement de
régime en Russie il avait vu que les
Russes remplacent Poutine
ça les Français sont contre les
politiques de changement de régime parce
que ils ont vu les résultats que ça
avait le changement de régime
les mêmes enjeux mais fallait pas les
mêmes puissances mais en Libye par
exemple
tout ça ça fait des échecs manifestes
donc c'est là et c'est d'ailleurs la
doctrine c'est intéressant de Manuel
Macron qui a dit c'est pas à nous à
changer les résines dans les autres pays
du monde bon ça c'est une différence
avec ce qu'on appelle les
néoconservateurs américains Jo Biden ce
temps un peu distancé du mouvement
et aujourd'hui les Américains disent
maintenant aux iconiens non il faut que
vous parliez avec Poutine donc là la
pollution américaine s'est rapprochée de
la position française c'est pas
l'inverse bon donc ils sont plutôt
d'accord mais pour les attentes
ce sont des images de tout à l'heure aux
alentours de 14h je sais Renaud que vous
êtes impatient
d'écouter le président Macron et le
président Biden tiens on se calme
à des révélations fracassantes ah bon
mais alors moi je vais vous faire des
révélations fracassantes vous savez ce
qu'ils vont dîner ce soir ah non alors
ça m'intéresse quoi la gastronomie
m'intéresse
il y aura 200 crustacés vivants des
homards
jusqu'à Washington un joli de la dépêche
de l'AFP du bœuf de la courge du potager
de la Maison Blanche un gâteau à
l'orange et alors jelly Biden a fait
venir les meilleurs fromages américains
notamment un bleu de l'Orégon qui était
la première production américaine a
remporté en 2019 les championnats du
monde du fromage mais il faudrait aussi
que au fromage par exemple en mangeant
du bleu de l'Orégon les Américains nous
annoncent qu'ils arrêtent de mettre de
la surtax sur le roquefort français qui
je crois et surtaxé en ce moment ça peut
être une négociation les toasts seront
portés avec un vin rosé pétillant
américain mais dans des Verts fabriqués
en France vous avez déjà assisté à ce
genre de dîner de grandes réception
j'imagine Renault comment ça se passe
est-ce que il y a de la franchise
finalement ce n'est que de la parade
tout le temps alors j'ai assisté à des
dîners d'État à l'Élysée j'ai
malheureusement jamais été invité à la
Maison Blanche pour un dîner d'État
j'aurais bien aimé j'étais directement
permis de me perdre un peu dans les
salons et j'avais
visité quelques salons comme ça parce
que la conférence de presse est en
retard de la Maison Blanche jusqu'à ce
que des
agents de sécurité
vous aviez fait l'innocent vous avez vu
pas mal de jolis tableaux donc pas mal
de tableaux français d'ailleurs et
alors les idées d'état vous avez quand
même toutes les Lite politique
américaine même les affaires qui étaient
invitées et puis
vous avez en France vous avez par
exemple le président et ses invités et
les premières dames sont dans de sorte
d'estrade en fait ils sont voilà et puis
la foule et puis allez Lisée vous avez
parfois
je me souviens d'un bâtard mon rachète
délicieux et l'Élysée elle a vu d'abord
et puis
alors on les voit parler entre eux mais
évidemment les conversations
sérieuses se font dans le bureau et par
exemple avec cette fameuse visite de
Kennedy avec Jacky Kennedy à Paris et
c'était merveilleux on avait vu
le Kennedy à l'Opéra qui avait enchanté
les Parisiens c'était une autre époque
en plus
des keno dit De Gaulle qui les
attendaient à Orly au pays de l'avion
etc donc tout le monde avait cru que ça
s'était extrêmement bien passé ensuite
on a su que les les rencontres en fait
en privé entre deux Gaules et dedy avait
été très dur puisque les Américains
voulaient absolument pas que les
Français se dotent d'une force nucléaire
indépendante il voulait que les Français
soient comme les Anglais dépend de deux
hors de Gaulle a été ferme il aura pas
du tout d'ailleurs tout dit sur les
intentions françaises mais il a refusé
toutes les offres de Kennedy et la
France dieu merci grâce à la force d'âme
de Gaulle c'est dotée d'une force
atomique indépendante et donc la France
est la seule puissance
occidentale de tes dermatomique à être
totalement indépendant puisque comme
vous le savez les Anglais ont besoin de
la clé américaine pour déclencher leur
missile je rapporte également les autres
cadeaux alors sachez que le Président de
la République
va offrir à offert sans doute déjà un
disque vinyle de la bande originale du
film de Claude Lelouch un homme et une
femme chabadabada voilà sachez que le
louche est dans la délégation Washington
également et puis alors aussi alors j'ai
vu voilà une coupe Christophe célèbre
maison d'orfèvrerie et d'art de la table
qui accompagnait entre autres les repas
à bord du prestigieux paquebot Normandie
voilà on essaye de se scaliner un peu on
se fait de jolis cadeaux visiblement le
Normandie qui était un magnifique
paquebot d'avant-guerre qui faisait donc
à liner ce qu'on appelait qui faisait le
Havre New York et qui pendant la guerre
de 40 il était à quai à New York qui ne
bougeait plus évidemment parce qu'il y
avait des sous-marins allemands qui
parcouraient l'Atlantique et il a brûlé
ce il a eu une incendie sur ce paquebot
et c'était donc une grande perte voilà
je vous ai dit que Thomas Pesquet était
dans la délégation Sophie ado la
nouvelle spationaute française de
l'Agence spatiale européenne Claude
Lelouch donc Christian Louboutin
également des chefs d'entreprise les
plus connues d'entre eux les plus
célèbres finalement auprès des français
Xavier Niel est là-bas Bernard Arnault
également c'est toujours important dans
ce genre de rencontre de venir avec des
chefs d'entreprise parce qu'il y a des
négociations à faire aussi oui alors
Bernard Arnault est très connu qu'il
avait été invité par Trump Bernardo est
très conduit parce que c'est quand même
le géant du luxe
pour les Américains la France et le pays
du luxe ils ont un tendance un peu à
oublier que la France est aussi
je dirais le pays de l'excellence
aéronautique
nous avions développé le Concorde
je suis pas sûr qu'ils étaient très
fair-play dans le traitement commercial
que ils ont fait au Concorde que nous
avions développé avec les Anglais mais
pour eux c'est la capitale du luxe et de
la mode c'est Paris et donc Arnaud c'est
important
Xavier nielk des rapports de famille
avec Arnaud
sa fille
qui est aussi puisqu'elle est la
dirigeante du groupe LVMH tout à fait et
Xavier Niel
et très présent dans les nouvelles
technologies on sait aujourd'hui qui
veut racheter une télévision
donc
mais tous les certainement d'autres je
crois qu'il y a aussi Rodolphe Saad
c'est-à-dire
le grand affréteur marseillais à la
grande
société de transport maritime
Marseillaise et Rodolphe Saad a acheté
récemment je dirais il y a un an le port
de Los Angeles donc c'est
GM c'est quand même une très grande
réussite française et donc
il est venu avec le président de la
République mais effectivement j'imagine
qu'il y a d'autres
peut-être le patron de j'en sais rien de
ça Gobain de vous voyez Emmanuel Macron
et Joe Biden ils se sont entretenus ce
ne sont pas des images en direct alors
nous les attendons les deux présidents
regardez dans le bureau Val au coin du
feu vous me demandez s'il y avait une
cheminée dans le bureau Val et bien
c'est le cas figurez-vous avec Martin
Luther King le buste de Martin Luther
King qu'on vient d'apercevoir derrière
Emmanuel Macron si vous nous rejoignez
les 18h15 les deux présidents de la
République deux présidents sont très
rentables on dit président de la
République aussi aux États-Unis ou pas
ah non du Président il est président des
États-Unis les États-Unis c'est une
république mais on n'utilise pas le mot
président de la République qui est
président des États-Unis se trouve que
les États-Unis c'est un pays qui est une
république qui est la forme républicaine
mais on dit pas président de la
République des États-Unis président des
États-Unis alors
vive les bureaux français parce que je
pense que là le feu il est alimenté au
gaz peut-être au gaz de je suis pas très
écolo voilà tandis que en France je
pense on est encore capables j'espère
l'Elysée d'avoir des vrais cheminées
avec du vrai bois parce que vous voyez
je vois pas le bois là je vois pas de
expert en cheminée également Renaud
Girard bon vous avez bien compris on est
en train de meubler évidemment parce que
les deux présidents devaient s'exprimer
il y a déjà 45 minutes ils sont en
retard cela va mettre le dîner de ce
soir il va falloir le remettre au chaud
quand il arriveront puisque tout ne sera
pas prêt on attend leur conférence de
prête alors combien de temps ça dure
généralement une conférence de presse
celle qu'on attend il ça peut
s'éterniser une demi-heure c'est quoi
les timing on sait oui il y a
j'imagine qu'il y aura trois questions
par président ça fait six questions
souvent d'ailleurs président américain
ils connaissent un peu leur journaliste
donc qui donne la parole comme ça mais
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
est-ce qu'il y aura des poules
quelquefois on fait des poules pour pas
qu'il y ait trop de journaliste c'est ça
mais
c'est intéressant de l'avoir j'espère
que nous ouvrons dans la salle notre ami
Philippe Gély directeur international du
Figaro qui a été correspondant très
longtemps aux États-Unis qui connaît
bien son affaire
et qui et peut-être le correspondant
actuel d'un jaune donc j'espère qu'on
les verra dans la salle pour poser des
questions aux
présidents de président mais c'est pas
du tout sûr qu'on leur donnera la parole
parce qu'il y aura évidemment
j'imagine beaucoup de monde dans cette
salle de presse-milar arrive que
les présidents donnent
des des
réponses
assez inattendues moi je me souviens de
la première exemple la première
conférence de presse
de Barack Obama
c'était en mars 2009 on m'avait envoyé
la balle parce que c'était sa première
et
on avait demandé au président à l'époque
il y avait avec Nicolas Sarkozy ou Obama
le directeur de la Banque centrale de
Chine à l'époque avait dit que il
fallait terminer le règne du dollar
comme monnaie de réserve et des changes
mondiales d'accord lui demander monsieur
le Président est-ce que c'est la fin
donc du règne du dollar comme monnaie
d'échanges de réserves mondiale il avait
eu une réponse très belle très
intelligente vraiment une réponse
politique il avait dit non monsieur je
ne crois pas que c'est la fin du dollar
que monnaie de réserve et des champs
mondiales parce que parce que nous
sommes le pays le plus stable
politiquement et le plus transparent du
monde et ça c'est assez juste les
Américains n'ont jamais changé de
discussion
ils sont transparents tout le monde
comprend comment marche la politique
américaine nous on change sans arrêt de
constitutions
même pas à la marge à la constitution
aux États-Unis
on en a pas fait depuis très longtemps
et c'est toujours le même système
chez nous on change les élections etc
bon et bah regardez on a fait quand même
un changement au début le Premier
ministre en France avait beaucoup
d'importance Georges Pompidou bien sûr
le Président c'est vraiment les les
grandes affaires aujourd'hui maintenant
on est les présidents s'occupe de tout
quoi on a pas vraiment changé
la Constitution ça c'est pas une
évolution politique bon mais mais disons
que politiquement on peut pas dire si on
a changé par exemple le
mandats n'ont jamais changé le mandat
c'est tous les quatre ans nous on a
changé quand même voilà pas pareil
d'être un président
voilà donc eux ils sont stables ils sont
stables et on comprend et ils sont
transparents c'est-à-dire que si vous
posez des questions
américaine et vous répondent et tout le
monde comprend comment on marche le
système bancaire américain la banque
centrale la réserve américaine le
Congrès des États-Unis
etc les cours de justice etc et c'était
une réponse très forte parce qu'en fait
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que ce
qui voulait dire Obama ça veut dire que
comme c'est un pays qu'on comprend bien
quand il y a une crise quand il y a un
peu de panique mondiale on propose sur
exactement ce qui se passe aujourd'hui à
cause de la guerre alors que les
États-Unis dépensent des folies en ce
moment
pour la guerre en Ukraine etc donc le
dollar à cause de leur dépense
faramineuse devrait baisser bah pas du
tout le dollar monte parce que c'est la
valeur refuge parce qu'ils sont tapés
fort et transparent et et donc les
capitaux vont les capitaux vont aux
États-Unis donc parfois il donne des
réponses intéressantes dans les
conférences de presse on suivra ça parce
que c'est dans on l'espère dans quelques
instants ça fait 51 minutes de trop tard
désormais 51 minutes que nous sommes
ensemble Renault et qu'on attend donc
cette conférence de presse entre le
président Macron et le président Biden
depuis la Maison Blanche pour cette
visite d'État la première donnée par Joe
Biden depuis qu'il est arrivé au pouvoir
et c'est donc la France qui reçoit cette
honneur
on oui je voulais vous poser cette
question parce que vous me dites c'est
des réponses intéressantes parfois ce
sera peut-être pas le cas cette fois
mais souvenez-vous d'une réponse par
exemple d'Emmanuel Macron à côté de
Vladimir Poutine alors
ce ne sont pas nos alliés les Russes
contrairement aux Américains en tout cas
à l'époque ça allait peut-être un peu
plus c'était à Versailles avec Emmanuel
Macron assez dur notamment sur les
questions de communication de fake news
sur
même sur la campagne de la
présidentielle qui aurait pu être
entachée des régularités à cause des
services secrets russes Emmanuel Macron
avait été très dur et la lumière Poutine
impassible
en 2017 d'abord les effectivement que
vous l'avez bien dit les Français sont
des alliés des américains notamment au
sein de l'Alliance atlantique donc nous
avons un traité d'alliance c'est à dire
que si la France est attaquée l'Amérique
est tenue de venir lui prêter secours
l'OTAN même chose c'est le temps ça
s'appelle le temps et même chose c'est
pour ça dire que lorsque les États-Unis
avaient été attaqué le 11 septembre 2001
Jacques Chirac avait fait le voyage
immédiat bon aux États-Unis en disant
vous avez été attaqué nous sommes prêts
on se souvient de la photo de Jacques
Chirac qui survole à New York en
hélicoptère à vous prêter nos à vous
donner nos forces spéciales pour vous
aider en Afghanistan etc donc ça nous
avons une alliance militaire avec les
Américains donc c'est quelque chose de
très important avec d'autres aussi avec
les enfin la même alliance avec des
Anglais les Allemands les Espagnols etc
et donc ça c'est la première chose nous
n'avons pas d'alliance avec la Russie
nous avons eu la Russie c'est grâce à la
Russie que Paris n'a pas été submergé
par les troupes allemandes en septembre
1914 puisque les Allemands pour aller se
battre sur les Russes ou un taquet sur
le fond russe ont dû retirer des
divisions du fond de la bataille de la
Marne si vous voulez nous savons été
d'une certaine Bouygues nous avons été
alliés
en 1944 45 nous étions avec l'URSS
contre contre les Allemands mais après
nous avons pas
du Tour de la guerre froide nous étions
évidemment du côté
occidental évidemment voilà et donc et
donc mais mais effectivement nous avons
eu notamment sous Chirac
des relations d'amitié très poussées
avec la Russie des
relations d'amitié ouvertes et avouer le
l'affaire de la Crimée c'est-à-dire
l'annexion de la Crimée en 2014 et
l'ingérence russe au Dombas à partir de
2014 l'ingérence militaire et les
premiers morts qui arrivent sur le sol
ukrainien vont effectivement beaucoup
refroidir les relations
Russo Francus avec avec la tentative
vous l'avez bien souligné importante de
Emmanuel Macron de dire à la fois la
vérité russe mais d'essayer de renouer
avec les Russes c'est l'invitation qui
fait en 2017
à Versailles pour fêter les faces 300ème
anniversaire des relations diplomatiques
entre la Russie et la France
c'est le sens de l'invitation d'Emmanuel
Macron à Brégançon à Vladimir Poutine à
dîner en 2019 malheureusement ces
initiatives n'ont pas donné
de résultats je pense que cependant que
Emmanuel Macron a eu raison d'essayer
quand on ne fait jamais suffisamment de
choses pour la paix
2019 2018 pour les 100 ans de
l'armistice c'est également voilà et il
est venu et il est triomphe avec
beaucoup de chef d'État bien sûr il est
venu aussi
aux obsèques de Jacques Chirac qui était
son ami donc ça c'était
c'était important mais
on ne fait jamais trop d'efforts pour la
paix en diplomatie on tente des choses
on réussit pas à tout coup si vous
voulez
de même que Emmanuel Macron a eu raison
d'essayer de rapprocher les Iraniens et
les Américains justement puisqu'il avait
failli organiser à New York une
rencontre entre le président Trump et le
président
raciste
le président Rohani pardon iranien à
l'époque qui lorsque les général des
Nations Unies et bien ça a pas marché la
dernière minute à cause du Guide suprême
iranien qui a mis son veto qui est à mon
avis une grave erreur iranienne mais
Emmanuel Macron a eu raison me
semble-t-il de temps de tenter cette
mission d'intermédiation presque une
heure de retard donc dans cette
visite puisque Emmanuel Macron et Jo
Biden avait prévu de s'exprimer aux
alentours de 17h30 c'est visiblement
raté les 18h26 tiens je provoque un peu
renoi est-ce qu'il peut y avoir un
problème est-ce qu'il peut y avoir de la
friture sur la ligne et on n'arrive pas
à s'accorder avant la conférence de
presse ou non c'est le protocole on a
trop on a trop blagué on arrive à peu en
retard 10 minutes en retard ce matin et
puis ça prend du retard écoutez
Emmanuel Macron nous est habitué quand
même à pas mal de retard oui mais alors
il se serait pas permis aux États-Unis
quand même non alors pourquoi est-ce que
du retard de
part et d'autre est-ce que c'est la
discussion qui se prolonge je ne le
crois pas
je crois plutôt à des raisons techniques
de choses qui sont pas prêtes
et peut-être aussi du fait que
le président Biden n'est plus tout jeune
donc il a la il a pas la même rapidité
dans la préparation des arguments oui
Macron
il faut pas du tout l'enterrer il vient
de
quasiment gagné
donc
lui donc il faut pas l'enterrer il est
plus malin que ça il a réussi à faire
passer des lois importantes au Congrès
donc Joe Biden ce n'est pas zéro si vous
voulez
mais c'est un homme
âgé
c'est un homme qui est une vision etc
alors que physiquement si vous voulez
Macron c'est une Ferrari c'est un homme
qui est une énergie absolument
incroyable donc Macron c'est un type qui
est capable est une Rolls-Royce plus
tranquille
voilà peut-être même diesel enfin une
rolls-royd diesel alors alors que lui
c'est vraiment une une Ferrari Macron et
donc et donc peut-être que ça prend un
peu plus de temps à ce que Biden qui
veut poser ses mots comprennent
ce qui peut dire ce qui ne peut pas dire
et qu'il s'accorde ensemble voilà
j'imagine que si c'était une une
conférence de presse entre Justin
Trudeau premier ministre du Canada à
côté
Emmanuel Macron j'imagine que entre
la discussion va beaucoup plus vite ça
veut pas dire que la le courant passe
pas si vous voulez ça veut pas dire ça
veut pas dire que si on est une
Rolls-Royce un peu lente ça veut pas
dire que sa politique est moins bonne
que celle d'une Ferrari puisqu'on peut
être on peut être
très rapide mais un agité sans vision
sans ligne directrice
Emmanuel Macron mais je dis que parfois
si parfois on en a vu des agités parfois
on a vu des agités on a vu des lignes
directrices bon moi je suis pas sûr j'ai
pas encore tout à fait compris
ce que ce que Emmanuel Macron voulait
faire en politique intérieure de son
deuxième mandat personnellement j'ai pas
tout à fait compris si vous voulez j'ai
pas tout à fait compris sur le plan de
la sécurité j'ai pas tout à fait compris
sur le plan de l'immigration et j'ai
même pas tout à fait compris sur le plan
financier parce que si vous nous sommes
dans il faut savoir que le FMI qui est
basé à Washington vient de rappeler à
l'ordre la France la France le plus
mauvais élève européen quand il m'avait
que les Italiens parce que c'est
finances sont dans une pagaille
incroyable avec un endettement qui
continue à à grossir et les Français
incapables d'avoir un budget qui est
payé par ses recettes fiscales alors
c'est plus le cas en Italie ou ce qu'on
appelle ils ont plus de déficit primaire
on meuble tellement qu'on parle de la
politique intérieure alors qu'on est sur
l'international
c'est que Bujo Biden Joe Biden lui il a
peut-être une vision plus claire et plus
compréhensible de
la politique intérieure américaine on ne
sait pas où ça va mener il y a des
problèmes
il a réussi à faire passer des lois
importantes notamment une loi de
financement des infrastructures mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que un président
pas besoin d'être une Ferrari pour être
un bon Président je comprends c'est la
présidence ça doit donner une ligne une
vision qui est acceptée par le peuple et
qui compréhensible et qui mène le pays
du côté monsieur Ronald Reagan était un
homme qui travaillait peu très peu 3
heures par jour
pas très cultivé pas inculte mais pas
très cultivé
sûrement pas l'intelligence d'Emmanuel
Macron sûrement pas l'agilité mais ça a
été un grand président
même la gauche américaine c'est un
président républicain reconnaît que
c'était un grand président des
États-Unis je crois qu'il y a personne
qui dit que ça a pas été un grand
président des États-Unis et bon voilà
pour que Emmanuel Macron devienne un
grand président français
des résultats qui sont se font un peu
attendre et
il faut qu'on comprenne exactement où on
va je ne suis pas sûr que les Français
aujourd'hui je crois que d'ailleurs le
président français veut à nouveau
s'exprimer s'exprime beaucoup je trouve
les noms français j'espère qu'il va
avoir des auditeurs à la télé je crois
qu'ils veulent s'exprimer bientôt qui
donne une vraie vision donc on avait un
tout petit peu enterré trop tôt Biden en
disant il est gâteux etc parce qu'en
fait il fait on dit qu'il est gâteux
parce qu'il fait des
il prend un mot sur qui promet
pas la même chose
physiquement il est tombé à vélo
il était un sommet asiatique il a parlé
de la Colombie alors qu'il voulait
parler du Cambodge bon ouais
le public américain rassurez-vous voilà
et mais bon mais ça veut pas dire qu'il
est cadeau ça veut pas dire que sur les
lignes de force qu'il faut imprimer à la
politique
américaine il n'est pas présent ça veut
pas dire ça si vous voulez et pour le
moment on le disait fini et bien moi je
suis pas du tout sûr que Joe Biden soit
fini vous savez quoi on se fait chambrer
mon cher Renault sur
Grégoire qui me dit bâillement soutenu
oui mais mon cher Grégoire
compliqué messieurs bayden et Macron
ceux qu'on attend voilà wall passe lui
qui nous dit il faut pas comparer les
époques non plus quand vous parlez de
Reagan voilà ce qu'on nous dit bon il
est 18h34 ça fait presque 1h qu'on
attend Emmanuel Macron et Joe Biden
cette conférence de presse Renault
Girard a encore de la salive et on va
pouvoir recommencer est-ce que c'est un
moment d'histoire bon c'était ma
première question pour ceux qui nous
rejoignent sur YouTube sur Le Figaro.fr
vous n'hésitez pas peut-être que les
deux présidents arriveront très vite
est-ce que c'est un moment d'histoire
parce qu'on le rappelle une telle visite
c'est rare c'est la première fois que
Joe Biden accorde une visite d'État à un
autre chef d'état depuis qu'il est
président des États-Unis oui ça applique
tout un protocole la visite d'État c'est
beaucoup plus long
c'est à l'évidence fait par amitié pour
Emmanuel Macron et pour réparer une
humiliation qui a été faite je crois que
Joe Biden c'était pas vraiment
et visiblement on voit que sur les
images que Emmanuel
Macron apprécie l'honneur fait à la à
lui-même et à la France vous voulez une
information Renault les journalistes
sont en train d'entrer dans la salle de
presse j'espère qu'on va nous verrons
Philippe Gély oui mais c'est justement
cette information donc ça a du retard
bonjour alors il y a eu quand même une
on attend évidemment cette conférence de
presse il y aura sûrement beaucoup de
choses à en tirer on a eu tout à l'heure
un discours c'était court des hommes se
sont exprimés lors de l'arrivée
d'Emmanuel Macron à la Maison Blanche
avec cette phrase il nous faut savoir
redevenir frère d'armes c'est la phrase
qui ressort évidemment de cette courte
allocution qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
c'est défini nous n'étions plus frères
il y a eu cette nous étions frères dames
justement pour les
les histoires de
soutien contre daesh au cure de
progressistes
direct et surtout du Nord de la série si
vous voulez
et là vous aviez des contingents
français
britannique et américains côte à côte
avec évidemment les Américains contents
les plus importants mais comme nous
sommes des grands alliés
nous avons ce qu'il faut comprendre que
dans la période contemporaine les
grandes opérations militaires du succès
ont été faits par les trois puissances
je pense par exemple à la Bosnie en fait
c'est une opération
bride qui a arrêté la guerre en Bosnie
franco-britannique et ensuite rejoint
par les Américains qui en 1995 a arrêté
la guerre en Bossi et donc lorsque vous
avez
la guerre contre daesh et bien vous avez
les trois
les vrais armées qui se battent les
Américains les Anglais et les Français
qui sont ensemble et ça c'était
donc ça c'était en Kurdistan enfin oui
dans les régions kurdes du nord de la
Syrie ce qu'on appelle le rojava et les
Américains avaient c'était une zone
Trump un film mauvaise manière à leurs
alliés en partant sans prévenir
puisqu'il y avait eu un deal entre Trump
et
Erdogan président turc à l'époque donc
là les Français les américains n'étaient
plus des frères d'armes puisque bien sûr
et donc aujourd'hui
redonnons des frères d'armes nous sommes
un peu des frères d'armes dans la guerre
d'Ukraine parce que
il y a évidemment bien sûr c'est pas
avoué mais il y a des forces spéciales
il y a des agents de la DGSE française
il y a des bérets verts américains qui
sont en Ukraine
il y a aussi des SAS britanniques tout
ça pour en fait former l'armée
ukrainienne alors c'est force spéciale
américaine britannique et française
ces éléments je dirais clandestins
ne combattent pas en première ligne mais
ils sont là pour former pour sans doute
donner des conseils aussi évidemment les
Ukrainiens ont été largement entraînés
et renseigné par les Américains
il me semble non le renseignement
américain tout changé
dans la guerre du crâne les Américains
vous savez les Russes sont attaqués de
manière cybernétique les Américains à
partir de
2014-2015 ils sont ingérés dans la
campagne électorale au moment de Trump
parce qu'ils avaient cru qu'ils Amérique
étaient faibles lorsque
Obama n'avait pas honoré sa ligne rouge
en Syrie vous savez Obama avait dit si
Bachar al-Assad utilise des armes
chimiques je le frapperai c'est une
ligne rouge il avait pas fait donc des
risques avaient mal interprété parce que
les américains
restent à peuple et une nation très
forte ils peuvent avoir des échecs au
Vietnam en Afghanistan dans toute leurs
expéditions
quasi coloniale si vous voulez ça ça ne
marche pas mais ça reste
quand même un peuple une armée très
forte une industrie très vivante une
technologie très supérieure aux autres
technologies et donc
et donc on ne peut pas on ne peut jamais
sous-estimer sous-estimer ce vecteur bon
vous savez ce qu'on va faire Renaud va
faire une petite pause voilà parce qu'on
attend les images on revient dès qu'on a
les images depuis Washington tiens je
répondrai à Grégoire quel est le
programme à la Nouvelle-Orléans parce
qu'Emmanuel Macron ira à la
Nouvelle-Orléans dès demain pour parler
de la Francophonie notamment on fait une
petite pause on attend la conférence de
presque comme une entre Joe Biden et
Emmanuel Macron elle devait commencer à
17h30 il est 18h41 nos journalistes sur
place nous disent ça y est on est en
train de rentrer dans la salle de presse
c'est imminent mais on a fait le tour on
a beaucoup parlé avec Renaud Girard on
revient dans quelques-uns on coûte pas
les les flux hein vous restez sur
YouTube sur Le Figaro.fr et dès qu'on a
des images promis on voulait remettre et
on revient avec Renault à tout de suite
nous sommes de retour Renault Girard du
Figaro international grand reporter
chroniqueurs international oui alors
cette conférence de presse elle a
presque 1h30 de retard mais ça y est
elle va bien débuter les journalistes
sont dans la salle on voit même Philippe
Gelly là vous reconnaissez peut-être pas
mais il est cachés là dans cette mode de
journaliste parce que cette conférence
de presse va enfin débuter si vous nous
rejoignez merci de nous suivre on est
sur Youtube on est sur le Figaro.fr vous
pouvez recommencer à nous envoyer toutes
vos questions je les transmets à Renault
qui y répond vous étiez à la Maison
Blanche vous avez pas eu la chance
d'être à ce genre de réception les
sapins de Noël sont de sortie
visiblement le décorum est plante
j'ai pas eu les sapins de Noël
effectivement c'était
conférence de presse dont j'ai parlé
c'est la première conférence de presse
d'Obama donc
c'était après son fait que les prisons
américains
Noël reste une fête très importante au
États-Unis
Dieu les Américains n'ont pas peur de
mettre des crèches aussi
catholique avoué
mais effectivement
c'est toujours l'hiver et froid aux
États-Unis mais maintenant
alors il est 13h Washington à 19h
presque 19h on est des moumouths etc
je pense qu'il fait pas chaud bon on va
voir ça au 7 degrés
bon on peut reprendre il nous faut
savoir devenir frère d'armes c'est ce
qui a dit Emmanuel Macron tout à l'heure
lors de son arrivée à la Maison Blanche
on attend si vous deviez poser une
question vous avez l'honneur de la
première question Renaud Girard laquelle
vous posez et pourquoi
bah moi la première question c'est je la
poserai à qui déjà je la poserai à
prise en Biden d'accord et je dirais ce
Viber ce président Renaud Gérard Le
Figaro le Girard du Figaro le l'Europe
et la France en particulier et la
première victime collatérale pas la
victime directe de la guerre en
Ukraine première victime c'est
évidemment
et puis les soldats russes je ne Soler
russe qui meurt mais la première victime
collatérale c'est de gens qui n'ont rien
à voir aucune responsabilité dans le
déclenchement de cette guerre qui sont
les Européens
sont la première victime parce que
il paye leur énergie beaucoup plus cher
ce qui n'est pas le cas des États-Unis
qui leur vendent du gaz de schiste à
très haut prix à ces Européens et qui
ont leurs propres et donc qui c'est une
guerre qui ne coûte rien aux États-Unis
et qui leur permet en plus dis donc les
armes quand même de vendre des armes de
des armes mais il faut marcher la
planche à billets parce que ils ont les
ils ont le score de Gaulle appelé le
privilège exorbitant l'isola
c'est-à-dire que le dollars reste la
masse
de réserve et donc on peut imprimer
autant de dollars qu'on veut c'est
toujours considéré comme quelque chose
qui a de la valeur nous les Européens
nous souffrons beaucoup
alors la question je dirais monsieur le
Président avez-vous là l'intention de
compenser financièrement les Européens
car ce sont eux qui payent beaucoup plus
que les États-Unis d'Amérique les
conséquences de la guerre en Ukraine et
il vous répondrai selon vous non
[Rires]
comme vous l'avez dit bah déjà nous
faisons beaucoup de choses donc ils
rappelleraient les âmes qui vivent etc
et il dit mais il dira il ferait je
pense qu'il fera une réponse
la même question
en disant oui évidemment
nous verrons
la France et l'Europe est un allié de
longue date etc et nous prendrons des
mesures je dirais de l'instruction à mon
secrétaire d'État de négocier ça avec
avec évidemment Bruxelles également
pour que
les Européens n'est pas trop à
souffrir nous sommes des alliés
évidemment mais les Américains
rassurez-vous payent leur part dans
cette guerre
nous souhaiterions qu'il s'arrête nous
n'avons pas le responsabilité dans cette
guerre donc je pense que oui je pense
qu'il répondra pas
très franchement et puis en plus parce
qu'il sait très bien que son congrès se
moquent totalement
ce que peuvent devenir les Européens le
concept
il a il a perdu la chambre il a perdu la
chambre il a perdu
représentants c'est ça merci
il a gardé le Sénat donc bon le Congrès
il l'a à moitié c'est ça que vous me
dites oui non mais c'est de toute façon
le Congrès a une politique c'est
indépendant de celle du président n'a
pas tellement changé par rapport à Trump
et Trump pas tellement changé par
rapport Obama le américain first c'était
déjà le protectionnisme américain
d'abord à vous intéresse de l'Amérique
le reste ben voilà adaptez-vous ça fait
penser au secrétaire finances je crois
de Dixon qui disait aux Européens
le de la et notre monnaie c'est votre
problème voilà et donc parce que vous
savez vous vous souvenez que les
Américains avaient changé avait
bouleversé l'ensemble du système
monétaire de ce qu'ils avaient eux-mêmes
construit en 1945 sans prévenir leur
partenaires européens ça avait été une
décision unilatérale qui a été annoncée
le 15 août
1971 par Dixon de l'abandon de la
convertibilité du de la en or qui
cassait en fait donc tout le système de
brettones sont évidemment avoir prévenu
préalablement
leurs alliés donc
en fait les
Américains sont un paquebot ils vont
dans une direction c'est aux autres
petits bateaux qui font partie de la
flottille de s'adapter de les suivre
c'est pas eux qui vont décider j'ai du
nouveau parce qu'un communiqué commun
vient de parvenir alors
première déclaration donc on transmet le
communiqué ce qui permet ensuite aux
journalistes de poser des questions si
j'ai bien compris j'imagine Biden et
Macron s'engagent à soutenir l'Ukraine
sur le site aussi longtemps qu'il le
faudra voilà
baiden et Macron s'engage à je cite
coordonner leur réponse au défi posé par
la Chine voilà et puis byden et Macron
salut le courage des manifestants
iraniens alors ça veut dire quoi la
deuxième chose oui c'est peut-être ça
qui veut dire qu'en fait la France et
l'Europe ne veut pas être un dégât
collatéral de la lutte
non létale pour que ce font l'Amérique
et Lessines pour la première place du
monde pour la place de premier première
puissance du monde et
il y a sorte de qul d'ego quand même
entre les Américains les Chinois
et
les Européens ainsi qu'ils n'ont pas
vraiment intérêt
à se mettre dans cette querelle d'autant
plus que
ils vendent beaucoup de choses chinois
vous avez parlé de LVMH
fait des ventes considérables en Chine
et quant aux allemands comme on sait ils
ont un commerce très important avec les
Chinois donc c'est ce que ça veut dire
la coordination de la réponse entre
c'est à dire quand il y a des sanctions
et notamment des sanctions
technologiques à l'égard des Chinois les
Français ne sont pas contre mais ils
veulent être prévenus
et ils veulent qu'on n'avait pas trop
loin dans cette guerre commerciale
contre la question de Momo encore
pourquoi lieu ne pratique pas le même
protectionnisme et je vous laisse y
répondre mais je vous dis attendez je
vous je vous cite ce qu'a dit Emmanuel
Macron hier il était au Congrès il a
parlé avec avec des membres des
représentants des députés il a parlé
avec des sénateurs et il leur a dit vous
allez peut-être régler votre problème
mais vous allez aggraver le mien voilà
ce qu'a dit le président de la
République
c'est ça il essaye de les faire changer
d'avis mais je lis partout qu'en fait il
a fait une croix là-dessus il sait très
bien que les Américains reviendront pas
sur sur ce protectionnisme et sur cette
inflation réduction a vous mais il veut
pouvoir faire la même chose en Europe et
dire voilà ils le font là-bas moi j'y
suis allé pour essayer de les faire
changer ils veulent pas bah tant pis on
fait pareil alors je pense ce serait de
bonne guerre de faire pareil je ne suis
pas sûr que Macron aura derrière lui
la majorité qu'il lui faudra des États
européens
pourquoi parce que il y a des pays comme
la Pologne qui vous disent moi je suis
l'esclave des États-Unis j'en suis très
content et comme ça
mais c'est ce que ça veut dire pourquoi
la Pologne c'est un esclave mais c'est
un esclave influenceur parce que les
Polonais aux États-Unis sont très
importants la communauté polonaise est
très importante à Chicago donc en fait
la communauté polonaise influe sur la
politique américaine est une bon la
politique étrangère Eden de soutien à la
Pologne et de rivalité
musclée contre la Russie évidemment les
ennemis de tout temps de des Polonais
c'est des Russes évidemment
et donc les le gouvernement polonais
c'est c'est en fait
on a l'impression que ce sont des suivis
c'est des esclaves mais en fait ils très
bien qu'ils influencent aussi la
politique de leur protecteur
bon peut-être pas très grande échelle
mais c'est pas direct mais vous pouvez
être sûr que les lobbys aux États-Unis
il y a quelque chose qui existe un peu
moins en France mais le lobby ukrainien
le lobby polonais et dans les pays des
territoires démocrates comme les états
du nord des États-Unis Chicago et cette
pizza c'est très polonais et très
d'accord mais oui donc vous me dites que
pour instaurer un tel protectionnisme
européen il faut l'avoir et donc
certains pays il faut la voie des Pays
Basque il faut avoir de la Pologne faut
la voie de la République tchèque etc etc
et ceux-là sont pas prêts et ceux-là je
suis pas sûr et je suis pas sûr même les
Allemands je ne suis pas sûr par exemple
Macron il a proposé un concept
d'autonomie stratégique européenne
et bien il est un peu le seul à la
vouloir
les autres ils parlent pas de
d'autonomie stratégique européenne ils
disent nous on est bien sous le
parapluie américain c'est ce que nous
dit oui ils ont les Russes à leur porte
et forcément ça peut aussi inquiéter
même si c'est pas tout à fait la même
question
et donc on peut rappeler peut-être non
parce que c'est pas clair pour tout le
monde forcément quand on parle de
protectionnisme américain il y a eu
notamment le vote de donc de cette
inflation réduction actes en fait ce
sont des énormes subventions pour
l'achat de produits américains
concernant la transition énergétique par
exemple les batteries les énergies
renouvelables les voitures électriques
ça veut dire que
[Musique]
multiples l'Europe ensemble d'accord
c'est pas la force ne décide plus
elle-même de ses droits de douane c'est
l'Union européenne l'Union européenne
mais les Américains font les droits
douanes ils ont mis des surtax sur
certains produits français le 20 le
fromage et d'autres j'imagine que
Emmanuel Macron va demander
boycotton les fromages américains alors
ils sont pas très bons mais sachez on
l'a dit tout à l'heure que le bleu de
l'Oregon sera à la table du président
des présidents ce soir mais
donc voilà ils ont ils ont une
une politique protectionniste et la
seule réponse
qu'on peut avoir parce qu'on ne se fait
pas trop d'illusions si on va essayer
d'avoir un processus de plainte auprès
de l'OMC l'Organisation mondiale du
commerce mais la seule chose c'est faire
la même politique en Europe parce que en
matière commerciale les Américains ne
comprennent que les rapports de force
c'est ce que vous m'expliquez tout à
l'heure les journalistes se sont assis
c'est peut-être une bonne nouvelle parce
que nous en sommes à une heure 41 de
retard dans cette conférence de presse
entre Joe Biden de Joe Biden et
d'Emmanuel Macron
19h11 en France 13h11 à Washington
cette visite qui va durer trois jours
parce que demain le président de la
République et on peut l'évoquer sera la
Nouvelle-Orléans pourquoi faire le
parler de la Francophonie c'est ça oui
puisque finalement cette Nouvelle
Orléans était une ville française où
il faut voir qu'en fait
si
Napoléon n'avait pas vendu la Louisiane
aux États-Unis
tout le centre et l'ouest américain
serait français et oui aujourd'hui
alors je suis pas sûr que la force
aurait pu garder ça très longtemps
tous les Acadiens
sont américains la faute à guidon la
faute à Napoléon voilà et donc
il y a il y a plus beaucoup de
francophonie
aux Etats-Unis
lorsque De Gaulle venait
dans les années 60 aux États-Unis ils
pouvaient encore s'exprimer en français
beaucoup d'Américains comprenaient alors
aujourd'hui
on a vu Macron s'exprimer en anglais
auprès des des
Bibliothèque du Congrès avec qui sont
mauvais accent anglais
parce que évidemment
la c'est très triste mais c'est comme ça
la Francophonie a beaucoup beaucoup
périclité par rapport
au début par rapport au même au milieu
du 20e siècle d'ailleurs même en 1945 si
vous voulez le français encore très
important dans le monde bien que il y a
eu la défaite française de 1940
puisque en 1945 c'est qu'il y a deux
langues de travail à l'ONU deux pas plus
silent vous avez le droit de vous
exprimer en silence et pour les
documents de travail de langues
l'anglais et le français deux langues de
travail à l'ONU aujourd'hui le français
qui est la langue des Jeux Olympiques
par exemple qui est de moins en moins
utilisé nous verrons l'an prochain dans
deux ans dans deux ans
alors en fait c'est une escale qui avait
été envisagée en avril 2018 lorsque
Emmanuel Macron était venu également
visiter
Trump à l'époque le président américain
pour le 300ème anniversaire de la ville
de La Nouvelle-Orléans fondée vous savez
par qui je vais vous le dire le Français
Jean-Baptiste Lemoine de Bienville voilà
ça n'avait pas pu faire donc ce
contretemps est réparé Emmanuel Macron
je vous cite l'Élysée confirmera son
attachement à la Francophonie
les soutiendra l'apprentissage de la
langue française dans les écoles
américaines il parlera aussi climat avec
le gouverneur de de Louisiane c'est un
état fragilisé par la montée des eaux
voilà le programme d'Emmanuel Macron ce
sera le troisième président français à
s'y rendre après Charles de Gaulle en
avril 60 et Giscard d'Estaing en 1976
nous attendons donc toujours cette
conférence de presse qui peut-être
n'arrivera jamais pendant Girard
peut-être nous ne savons pas écouter moi
je suis un peu inquiet pour eux parce
que
je trouve vous avez cité le menu il y a
de la courge dont
il est que 13h
dîner c'est le menu du dîner je voulais
que je vous remercie pour ceux qui nous
rejoignent
200 crustacés quand même
qui ont fait leur dernier voyage jusqu'à
Washington voilà du bœuf de la courge du
potager de la Maison Blanche j'espère
qu'ils n'ont pas que Hydroïdes parce que
elle est en train de pourrir si ça se
trouve un gâteau à l'orange voilà et
puis on l'a dit ce fameux bleu de
l'Orégon avec un vin rosé pétillant
américain je suis pas sûr que ce soit
excellent ça c'est peut-être une écoutez
moi je trouve qu'on est méchant pour le
vin américain je ne connais pas le VIN
ROSE
et le vin de c'est ce grand cinéaste
Francis Ford Coppola qui bien sûr
extraordinaire parce qu'il faut
reconnaître que le cinéma américain
c'est quelque chose
au cinéma français le cinéma français en
ce moment c'est nul ici
c'est vrai en France on a pu enfin on a
pu la personne depuis les moines de
tibéry je crois qu'on a pu un grand film
vous aimez personne bah je sais pas
parce que vous pouvez m'en citer un
depuis les moins de Tibérine
par exemple
osons c'est un bon réalisateur non ouais
mais qu'est-ce qu'il a fait à récemment
qui on a assis comment le réalisateur de
Back Nord comment il s'appelle
ah j'ai perdu son nom enfin bon on n'est
pas là pour parler de cinéma je vois le
Corée et donc Cédric Gimenez voilà c'est
vrai non vous aimez pas bon vous êtes
vraiment et après vous me dites que le
français ne brille plus à
l'international mais si vous Renault
Girard vous commencez à détruire nos
films français on est mal embarqué bon
en tout cas il y a du bon vin
américain notamment dans la nappavalée
d'accord il y a des très bons Chardonnay
moi je trouve et même du très bon vin
rouge et même ce Francis Ford Coppola il
fait du très bon vin rouge donc vous
pouvez le voir si je cherche Francis
Ford Coppola 20 je peux commander son
vin sur Internet rouge absolument et
donc à l'égard du vin américain je ne
suis pas raciste j'adore le vin français
dites-le quand même rassurer nos
attentes
c'est incomparable et je rappelle parce
que c'est
pour la santé et j'imagine que le
président se soit très attention est-ce
que mais c'est vrai alors les
journalistes j'imagine que les
présidents sont en train d'arriver et
bien enfin Renaud Girard nous écoutons
ce qu'il se passe à la Maison Blanche et
on débrief juste après
[Musique]
hier soir
particulièrement apprécié le temps que
Jil et moi-même avions passé avec
Brigitte et Monsieur Macron ça fait
longtemps qu'il n'était pas venu à
Washington
de nos alliés les plus puissants et le
plus historique
très capable
Emmanuel est également devenu un ami
nous partageons les mêmes valeurs
et nous devons faire face aux mêmes
défis
nous avons quelques désaccords mais
fondamentalement nous sommes
dans la même longueur d'onde
aujourd'hui la France et les États-Unis
ainsi que tous les alliés de l'OTAN et
du G7
se tiennent unis contre la Russie et son
invasion de l'Ukraine
nous continuons de soutenir le peuple
craignant alors qu'ils défendent leur
famille leur maison
et leur souveraineté nationale
aujourd'hui nous affirmons à nouveau ce
que j'ai dit
nous tenons unis contre cette brutalité
leurs hôpitaux leur souveraineté contre
l'agression
je voudrais vous remercier monsieur le
président
pour l'accueil que le peuple français a
fait à des réfugiés des milliers de
réfugiés ukrainiens
des milliers de personnes en ligne
de vivre des peuples qui l'attaque
il tente de crème à travers les coupures
d'énergie à travers une crise
non seulement à travers le crème mais
dans le monde entier mais il n'y
arrivera pas
nous allons mettre la Russie devant ses
actes
[Musique]
nous travaillons ensemble pour soutenir
le Moyen-Orient
on l'appelle la prospérité dans ces
régions je vais particulièrement
reverser monsieur Macron
montre à la Russie et à sa guerre
elle nous assurons que les rangs ne se
procurent jamais l'arme nucléaire
sommet en Afrique
la France a énormément de choses à
apporter
africains
la paix et la prospérité
la défense de nos activités spatiales
et nos efforts scientifiques
ainsi que le climats
de développer des énergies nouvelles de
durables
j'ai de côté de la cantique nos équipes
en suivant ces sujets de très près
incroyables pour développer la santé
autour de moi
pour atteindre notre but
d'arriver ici à 2030 à la fin de
l'épidémie
des fonds considérables et sauver de
l'écosysie
on serait là jusqu'à l'heure du début
en soulignant
il ne faut particulièrement
forte pour les générations
je vous remercie à nouveau pour tout ce
que nous nations font ensemble nos
collaborations
à vous la parole
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le Président
et je vais vous dire combien nous sommes
je me disais ce matin à la fois et mieux
honorer ma délégation et moi-même
accueilli par vous en cette première
visite d'État sous votre administration
nous l'avons l'un et l'autre 10 ce matin
vous venez de le rappeler ce bâti sur
une histoire qui nous oblige et nous
dépasse parce qu'elle est faite de
s'enverser parce qu'elle est faite
d'engagement réciproque je dirais à
l'échelle des siècles à chaque fois que
les choses vitales et essentielles ont
été en jeu
nous avons été là l'un pour l'autre
sans coup fait rire et sans aucun doute
et c'est ce qui doit structurer le reste
c'est cet esprit qui prévaut
dans le contexte que nous vivons depuis
le mois de février dernier vous l'avez
rappelé je vais pas redire ce que
parfaitement décrit le président Biden
mais Sergio vous avez très bien dit ce
que nous faisons ensemble en Ukraine
nous avons très clairement condamné
cette guerre immédiatement nous avons
mené toutes les actions diplomatiques
pour condamner cette guerre c'est les
crimes de guerre qui sont commises par
la Russie sur le sol de l'Ukraine et
nous soutenons à la fois l'armée
ukrainienne dans sa résistance la
population civile pour résister je veux
ici vraiment remercier les États-Unis
d'Amérique pour la nature et la
magnitude de l'aide qui est fournie
parce que cette guerre touche le sol
européen
elle nous touche je dirais encore plus
directement et vous avez fait le choix
de déployer beaucoup de moyens pour
participer à l'effort collectif
dans ce contexte là la discussion de ce
matin nous a permis d'une part de
confirmer les initiatives que nous
prendrons encore dans les prochains
jours et prochaines semaines pour
renforcer l'aide justement
aux troupes ukrainiennes et leur
permettre de résister nous avons aussi
décidé de continuer d'agir ensemble pour
aider la population civile ukrainienne a
résisté car on le voit bien aujourd'hui
l'effort de guerre russe se concentre
sur les infrastructures civiles
multiplier
les exactions pour désespérer la
population civile et rendre l'hiver
impossible c'est ce pourquoi nous avons
décidé d'organiser le 13 décembre
prochain et une conférence de soutien à
la résilience ukrainienne à Paris et je
vous remercie pour le soutien apporté
les trois de coordination en la matière
nous avons souhaité aussi continuer le
travail et trois avec en particulier le
président Zelinski autour des 10 points
qui ont été proposés par ce dernier et
je vais ici saluer aussi l'effort qui
est fait par
président zellinski pour engager un
chemin de paix possible et durable en
même temps qu'il conduit une résistance
héroïque depuis maintenant plusieurs
mois et je crois que nous avons toujours
été sur la même ligne
aider l'Ukraine à résister ne rien céder
à nos valeurs et aux principes de la
Charte des Nations Unies évitez tout
escalade incontrôlée dans ce conflit et
acter que au moment qui sera opportun
dans les conditions pour leur territoire
qui revient aux ukrainiennes aux
Ukrainiens de décider nous serons là
pour aider à bâtir la paix
je pense qu'à cet égard avoir la clarté
mes positions qui sont les vôtres et
pour nous importante car notre objectif
nous l'avons discuté de bâtir une paix
durable
nous avons également évoqué les
conséquences directes et indirectes de
cette guerre et les conséquences en
matière de sécurité alimentaire et
énergétique pour l'ensemble de la
planète et nos initiatives communes au
G20 comme au G7 vont dans ce sens et
nous avons pu le rappeler également
ensemble ce matin pour pouvoir essayer
pour nombre de pays de pallier les
conséquences de ce conflit sur leurs
économies nous avons aussi
ce matin une très bonne discussion sur
l'aérer et les textes récemment pris par
l'administration américaine et nous
avons décidé ensemble comme vient de
dire le président que nous allions
synchroniser nos approches et nos
agendas pour investir dans les
industries émergentes critiques tels que
les semi-conducteurs l'hydrogène les
batteries les sujets industriels qui
sont absolument décisifs parce que au
fond nous partageons la même vision et
la même volonté
président Biden veut créer des emplois
industriels
dans la durée pour son pays et bâtir une
industrie forte et sécurisée des
approvisionnements et c'est exactement
la même vision que nous portons et c'est
pourquoi nous avons donné mandat à nos
équipes de poursuivre ce travail en
coordination étroite pour pouvoir
justement trouver des solutions sur les
sujets
identifiés et surtout avec une
coordination avec l'ensemble des
Européens d'une part et avec vous
pouvoir bâtir un agenda qui nous permet
d'avoir plus d'emples industriels et aux
États-Unis et en Europe et garantir la
force et la résilience de nos chaînes
d'approvisionnement de manière intégrée
dans notre volonté et de garder une
forte intégration à cet égard
ce travail en européen c'est aussi celui
que nous voulons conduire sur à peu près
tous les sujets de l'agenda mais vous
l'avez rappelé président à l'instant
ce que nous voulons faire aussi c'est
développer plusieurs sujets d'avenir et
les séances de travail que nous avons pu
avoir hier ce que nos ministres nos
équipes ont pu préparer nous permettent
d'acter aussi un agenda dirait d'avenir
et d'espérance l'évoquais ce matin dans
plusieurs domaines le spatial avec à la
fois des sujets de recherche
d'exploration mais aussi des sujets
industriels d'avenir le nucléaire civil
avec là aussi des nouveaux sujets de
recherche comment en particulier sur les
techniques les plus avancées car je
crois pouvoir dire que pour l'un et pour
l'autre le nucléaire civil fait partie
de la solution énergétique dans laquelle
nous croyons et qui seul permet de
réussir à créer des emplois avoir une
énergie sur compétitive et atteindre
notre objectif de neutralité carbone en
2050 nous avons eu aussi l'occasion
d'avoir beaucoup d'échanges sur le
quantique entre nos différents acteurs
et en matière de technologie
et
justement d'innovation là aussi nos
délégations sont là pour eux illustrer
tout le travail qui est fait pour
continuer d'avancer sur un agenda commun
enfin c'est aussi nos engagements sur
les grands sujets internationaux qui
je dirais irrigue notre relation je ne
serai trop redire ici combien nous avons
été heureux de voir votre choix qui
correspondait à vos engagements
historiques et vos engagements de
campagne de revenir
sur les grands sujets internationaux
qu'il s'agisse du climat ou de la santé
cela change la donne et là où nous avons
pu résister pendant quelques années nous
avons pu réengager les efforts et en
cette Journée mondiale de lutte contre
le sida je veux ici
dire de concert avec vous combien nous
continuons à tenir cet agenda en effet
des indications en 2030 et combien nos
deux pays ont deux concerts vrai ces
dernières années dans le financement du
fond mondial nous nous sommes les
principaux au contributeurs pour lutter
évidemment contre le VIH mais également
contre la malaria et plusieurs autres
virus qui avagent en particulier les
pays les plus fragiles et les
populations les plus fragiles nous
continuerons cette effort sans relâche
c'est la même détermination qui prévaut
dans notre relation pour avancer
ensemble sur les sujets de climat et de
biodiversité au-delà de cette volonté
d'avancer sur les innovations et un
agenda de solutions sur le climat
nous avons acheté là aussi plusieurs
initiatives lors de cette visite d'État
bâtir des solutions de financement
innovants pour aider les pays émergents
et les pays les plus fragiles pour leur
permettre de nous accompagner sur cette
route du développement et du climat et à
cet égard vous aurez un rôle essentiel
dans le sommet que nous comptons
organiser
à l'été prochain de par ce nouveau
partenariat entre le Nord et le Sud qui
s'inscrit pleinement d'abord dans la
logique de ce que nous avons fait
ensemble pour réallouer plus de moyens
vers les pays du Sud mais aussi de
l'agenda de réforme de nos institutions
multilatérales financières qui est
indispensable pour réussir cet objectif
en particulier
existants et puis en matière de
biodiversité nous avons eu l'occasion
hier de parler avec le caucus compétent
nous avons eu des discussions à
plusieurs
reprise ensemble notre volonté et là
aussi d'avoir un agenda
extrêmement ambitieux et en particulier
nous
œuvrerons ensemble pour préparer le One
forest Summit qui se tiendra sur le sol
africain au Gabon à la fin du premier
trimestre prochain ce sujet
étant aussi au cœur de ce que vous
voulez soulever avec les États africains
que vous accueillerez dans quelques
jours à Washington et donc là aussi sur
ce volet il y a une forte convergence
entre nos vies enfin nous continuerons
d'être engagés ensemble dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme et pour la paix
en étant à vos côtés j'ai évidemment une
pensée pour nos soldats qui sont tombés
en Afghanistan en proche Moyen-Orient en
Afrique durant ces dernières années pour
se battre pour la sécurité
de ces régions du monde et de nos pays
et je veux ici une fois encore vous
redire notre engagement nous continuons
à être engagés dans notre coalition
internationale Proche et Moyen-Orient à
travers
notre action militaire et nous
continuerons de l'aide de manière très
étroite car nous n'avons pas fini ce
combat et je pense qu'il est important
de le rappeler à tous nos alliés et tous
nos partenaires nous devons continuer
d'agir contre le terrorisme islamiste
dans le prochain Moyen-Orient cet agenda
n'est pas terminé et je voulais vous
remercier aussi pour l'aide précieuse
que nous avait apporté durant toutes ces
dernières années que vous continuez nous
apporter dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme au sel et en Afrique de
l'Ouest c'était des précieuses et nous a
permis ces dernières années y compris
ces dernières semaines d'avoir des
résultats extrêmement concrets et donc
nous continuerons là aussi devraient
ensemble je pourrais également passer
l'après-midi de concert avec vous à
égrainer tous les sujets sur lesquels
nous travaillons ensemble de
l'adopacifique et plus particulièrement
de l'organisation notre présence dans
l'océan Indien je voudrais avoir un mot
pour au fond peut-être remettre les
choses dans le bon ordre
de remercier la France pour son aide
sur l'accord qui a été trouvé historique
entre Israël et le Liban
nous avons fait le maximum pour aider à
finaliser je crois quand même que
l'honnêteté me conduit à dire que
c'était essentiellement vous qui avez
fait le travail et donc je pense que
dans ce moment c'était un travail
essentiel et je veux toute
particulièrement vous en remercier pour
le Liban qui nous est si cher et qui
avait besoin de cet accord au-delà des
sujets qui sont au cœur de l'agenda
libanais pour les prochaines semaines et
les prochains mois voilà Mesdames et
Messieurs ce que je souhaitais dire et
pour finir
je souhaitais vraiment remercier le
président Joe Biden parce que ce qu'il a
dit je peux
le dire à son endroit ça n'est pas
simplement un dirigeant avec lequel nous
partageons beaucoup de valeurs beaucoup
de combat c'est une région avec lequel
nous avons des discussions très franche
et très directes et respectueuse et
engagée sur tous les sujets c'est aussi
devenu un ami et je vous tenais à te
remercier pour l'accueil qui nous est
fait l'honneur qui nous est fait mais
surtout l'importance dans ce moment de
pouvoir passer du temps ensemble et
prendre des décisions pour notre avenir
commun merci infiniment
enfin que bonjour
j'ai commencé par la démo fournisseur
celui qui
réussit à passer à faire passer les
contrats avec Israël c'est Emmanuel qui
a réussi à passer
quatre en totale
de l'AFP
est-ce que vous allez repartir de régime
le reste en français
je m'en occupe
pas je ne m'excuse pas
depuis que j'ai passé cette loi
ça fait presque 360 milliards de dollars
d'investissement pour le climat dans
toute l'histoire
qui doit évoluer qui doit s'adapter par
exemple il y a une provision dans cette
loi qui dit que il y a une exception
pour tous ceux qui ont un accord
d'échange libéral avec moi ça ça a été
ajouté par un membre du Congrès des
États-Unis qui a reconnu
pas seulement les accords libéraux il y
a beaucoup de choses qu'il faut qu'on
peut fine mais l'essence c'est que les
États-Unis doivent continuer
et c'est que l'Europe
de ne pas dépendre la chaîne de
distribution de quiconque en dehors de
notre contenu
de faire la même chose
donc nous pouvons faire des petits
changements qui pourront prendre la
collaboration plus simple pour la
participation des pays européens
mais c'est encore en cours c'est un
travail en cours
il n'y a jamais eu d'intention dans
l'écriture de cette loi
d'exclure des alliés ce n'était pas du
tout notre attention l'intention c'était
de nous assurer que nous ne n’étons plus
dans une position de dépendance quand
nous avons dit pendant la pandémie
les chaînes de distribution étaient
coupées notamment en Chine on a plus la
possibilité d'acheter des puces la Chine
a refusé de les vendre ce que je veux
vous dire c'est que on est de retour sur
le marché l'Europe et de retour sur le
marché et nous allons
de créer de l'emploi mais pas aux dépens
de l'Europe
ce que nous avons échangé avec le
président Biden ce que président Biden
vient d'ailleurs de dire est-ce que
j'évoquais hier
les États-Unis d'Amérique ont pris une
législation pour leur industrie leur
pays avec un objectif que nous
partageons
créé plus d'emploi
créer des opportunités pour les classes
moyennes et réussir à accélérer la
transition climatique
la réalité c'est que les conséquences et
notre discussion a permis de
parfaitement montrer que ça n'est
absolument pas l'objectif des États-Unis
de le faire mais une des conséquences de
cette législation et que sur des projets
qui étaient en train de se développer
sur le continent européen l'écart
subventions et tels que ces projets
risquent de tomber
ça n'est pas l'intention du président
Biden j'ai pu hier d'ailleurs discuter
avec plusieurs sénateurs et
représentants congrès ils m'ont assuré
que ça n'était pas non plus leur
intention et donc la France n'est pas
venue ici demander en quelque sorte pour
son économie telle ou telle exception on
est venu partager la manière dont nous
visions les conséquences de cette
réglementation et à un moment au fond
l'actualité nous sommes d'agir encore
plus de manière concertée ensemble face
au défi mondiaux de resynchroniser comme
j'ai pu le dire ça y est de trouver une
dynamique positive nouvelle pour se dire
clarifier quelles sont nos objectifs et
comment agir ensemble la discussion de
ce matin pour moi a été parfaitement
claire et j'ai senti d'ailleurs la même
intention chez l'ensemble des membres
du Sénat comme des représentants hier
la volonté du président Biden est de
refaire ici une industrie forte et
d'avoir
en quelque sorte de sécuriser les
solutions technologiques pour l'avenir
la France peut exactement la même chose
pour elle-même et nous nous battons jour
et nuit depuis un peu plus de 5 ans pour
faire la même chose dans notre pays ce
qui nous a permis de stopper
près de 15 ans de désindustrialises de
désindustrialisation en France et de
recréer des emplois industriels et des
solutions dans notre pays on veut juste
continuer de faire cela et donc on va le
faire ensemble c'est pourquoi nous avons
décidé en lien avec les autres Européens
la Commission européenne d'avoir un
travail qui doit être un travail
maintenant technique
en quelque sorte ses effets en dominos
qui pouvaient exister sur les projets
qui étaient en train de se développer en
Europe soit réglé
on veut réussir ensemble pas l'un contre
l'autre
ça a été clair et c'est ce qui ressort
de ce matin
et c'est exactement la philosophie
que je partage et c'est celle dont nous
avons besoin
bonjour Messieurs les Présidents William
Galibert pour la radio RTL pour
compléter la question de ma collègue
monsieur bayden en français on dit qu'il
y a pas d'amour qu'il n'y a que des
preuves d'amour est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que votre ami français
repart entièrement rassuré que vous avez
rassuré sur les questions économiques
vos alliés européens et puis pourrait-on
avoir quelques précisions
supplémentaires est-ce que vous vous
êtes fixé monsieur Macron des échéances
précises pour ces discussions
économiques des secteurs précis sur
lesquels vous attendez peut-être des
aménagements de des politiques
économiques américaines merci
pour être très clair d'abord nous nous
avons un travail en européen qu'on va
faire
c'est que sur les semis conducteurs
l'hydrogène les batteries notre
industrie on va continuer d'avancer en
européen et bien nous ne sommes pas là
pour en quelque sorte de demander une
preuve d'amour on était là pour se
mettre d'accord sur une stratégie et
clarifier les choses qui méritaient de
l'être je considère que la discussion
l'a fait maintenant nous nous avons
notre propre travail peut pas demander
aux États-Unis d'Amérique de prendre une
loi pour régler les problèmes de
l'Europe donc nous en européen on doit
aller plus vite et plus fort pour avoir
le la même ambition et réussir justement
à se mettre aussi en synchronie et de
l'autre côté nous avons clarifié
aujourd'hui les choses il y a plusieurs
déjà qui existent
et c'est dans les prochaines semaines et
les prochains mois que nous allons
clarifier ça mais ça va assez vite parce
qu'en fait nos projets sont en train de
se développer donc pour moi il y a une
grande clarté stratégique dans les
échanges de ce matin il y a eu beaucoup
de sincérité beaucoup de franchises et
donc à partir de là je considère que les
discussions des prochains jours tu auras
déjà avec la Commission européenne les
discussions qu'on aura dans les
prochaines semaines en lien étroit avec
nos partenaires allemands nos autres
partenaires européens et la Commission
et l'administration américaine vont
permettre de clarifier sans difficulté
ce sujet je repars confiant mais aussi
lucide sur ce qui est aussi à faire du
côté européen
c'est une bonne chose
OK
pour vous et Monsieur Macron j'ai une
question pour vous sur l'Ukraine tout
d'abord monsieur baiden président
[Musique]
est-ce que les travailleurs
le rail américain ont le droit à une
journée de congé comme tous les autres
Américains quand vous avez
aussi un contrat de personne ne m'aurait
pu qu'on essaier tout ce qui est sorti
de ce contrat c'est ce congés payés ça
fait des années que j'essaye d'obtenir
ces congés payés pour les travailleurs
du rail de pitzané mais les républicains
votent contre ils on ne peut pas y
arriver on est une des seules nations du
monde qui n'a pas de conseils pour aller
payer pour les ouvriers
en fait entre temps ils ont un
augmentation de salaire de 43%, il y a
beaucoup de choses qui sont sorties de
cet accord
mais là il y a un seul
sujet qui reste
emploi et une récession
et beaucoup mieux que ce qu'ils avaient
au préalable
et ils ont tous été d'accord au fait
de 14 qui ne fait pas d'accord mais la
majorité
ont signé cet accord lorsque je leur ai
présenté
voici l'histoire
ce n'est pas parce qu'on va passer
c'est Dieu le veut d'ici vendredi
nous allons abandonner les congés nous
allons continuer de nous battre pour les
congés payés non seulement pour les
travailleurs mais tout le travail
américain
ça va certainement surprendre nos amis
européens qu'il n'y a pas de congés
payés aux États-Unis d'Amérique nous
sommes dans les seuls pays dans le monde
il est temps étant que nous mettons à
jour voici le contexte dans lequel tout
cela s'est passé
tout le monde tout le monde a signé ce
contrat il y avait quatre syndicats
qui ne l'ont pas aimé mais je pense
qu'on va réussir à obtenir un accord
on va éviter la grève
continue d'avancer on va y retourner
et nous obtiendrons les congés payés
pour tous
demande au Congrès
38 milliards de dollars supplémentaires
pour les crèmes
ils ne veulent pas
est-ce que vous avez confiance dans le
fait que les États-Unis pour continuer
de donner les moyens à l'Ukraine de se
défendre dans les prochains mois
j'ai besoin de l'Ukraine de négocier
alors que l'hiver
arrivement vers le crâne et son peuple
je vais simplement vous dire
nos donations
sont faites de valeurs et d'histoire
ce qui compte en Ukraine ce n'est pas
quelque chose qui est très loin d'ici
dans un petit pays très loin en Europe
il s'agit de défendre nos valeurs
il s'agit de défendre nos principes
il s'agit de ce des engagements qu'on a
pris ensemble dans la charte de des
Nations Unies protéger la souveraineté
et l'intégralité territoriale des pays
c'est pour ça que je crois
que le soutien fort des États-Unis à
l'Ukraine est très important non
seulement pour le crâne pour les
Européens
c'est pour cela que nous vous remercions
mais aussi pour la stabilité de l'ordre
mondial aujourd'hui
si nous considérons que vous pouvez
abandonner ce pays
abandonné tous ces principes cela
signifie qu'il n'y a plus de stabilité
possible dans ce monde donc je pense que
c'est extrêmement important que les
États-Unis soient si impliqués je suis
confiante parce que je pense que votre
peuple
et vous représentants
comprennent ces objectifs
nous allons nous-mêmes continuer notre
soutien augmenter notre soutien
militaire et économique
nous augmentons également notre soutien
humanitaire
concernant votre deuxième question
nous ne pousserons jamais les Ukrainiens
à aller à la table de la négociation
pour un accord qu'il ne l'aurait pas
ne leur correspond pas et ils sont si
courageux et ils défendent alors leur
territoire
avec grande intégrité
ils ne pourront jamais construire une
peste durable
si nous ne respectons pas leur souhait
et leur jugement sur le meilleur moment
pour négocier le futur de leur
territoire
ce sera la dernière question
Emmanuel Macron doit s'entretenir dans
les prochains jours les prochaines
semaines avec Vladimir Poutine le lien
est maintenu depuis le début de la
guerre vous n'avez pas toujours été
d'accord avec cela est-ce que
aujourd'hui vous approuvez l'approche du
président français puis une deuxième
question pour pour vous deux alors que
la guerre en Ukraine semble aujourd'hui
à un tournant est-ce qu'il vous semble
réaliste que le président zellenski
conditionne l'ouverture de négociations
à un retour j'allais dire dans le giron
ukrainien de la Crimée merci
pour que cette guerre s'arrête
rationnellement Poutine se retire de
l'Ukraine il paraît apparemment il ne va
pas le faire
et il est en train de payer le prix
il crée un carnage effroyable sur la
population civile des hôpitaux
les écoles c'est terrible ce qu'il fait
aucun plan pour contacter Monsieur
Poutine monsieur Poutine il faut que je
choisisse mes mots avec précision
je suis prêt à parler avec Monsieur
Pétigny
pour sortir de cette guerre mais tu n'as
pas l'air d'en avoir actuellement
en consultation avec mes amis de l'OTAN
la France je serai ravie de m'asseoir à
la table avec Monsieur Poutine pour
l'instant il ne veut pas montrer
l'intérêt à le faire en attendant il est
critique que nous soutenions le peuple
très bien conquérir
ils arrivent à occuper ce territoire
pendant les cinq dix prochaines années
sur tout ce qu'il avait prévu il croit
et qu'il a été accueilli à bras ouverts
Legrand
l'identité russe etc etc
il a fait une erreur de calcul sur toute
la ligne
la question est donc comment est-ce
qu'il sort de cette situation
je suis tout à fait très
à parler avec lui
et je le ferai avec mes alliés de l'OTAN
mais pas tout seul
sur
la question que vous posez et
les pré conditions ou les conditions qui
sont mises par le président
ukrainien je pense que ce qui est
important pour nous tous de regarder
c'est qu'au moment même où l'Ukraine est
en train de résister de subir des crimes
de guerre
de subir des attaques sur ces
infrastructures civiles de mener des
contre-offensives le président Zelinski
a proposé un plan de paix en 10 points
et je pense que notre devoir c'est
d'engager le travail avec lui parce
qu'il y a une vraie volonté de la part
des Ukrainiens d'aller sur le terrain de
la discussion et nous le reconnaissons
et nous le saluons
et je peux ici vous dire pour avoir été
pendant plusieurs années
responsable du suivi de ce qu'on
appelait le format Normandie et donc de
la mise en oeuvre des accords de Minsk
la dernière réunion qu'il y a eu entre
le président zellinsky et le président
Poutine elle date c'est d'ailleurs la
seule de décembre 2019 et nous étions à
cette époque là avec la chancelière
Merkel
je peux vous dire que j'ai vu un
président sincère qui voulait discuter
et négocier et le président zeninski
depuis son élection jusque au mois de
février dernier il n'a eu de cesse de
vouloir négocier celui qui a décidé de
lancer une guerre c'est le président
Poutine j'en étais le témoin direct y
compris par le déplacement que j'ai pu
faire en Russie et en Ukraine au début
du mois de février donc il est légitime
que le président zéniti est très
conditions pour négocier maintenant nous
nous devons en travailler la substance
de ce qui peut être à terme un accord de
paix et ensuite c'est l'évolution des
prochaines semaines et des prochains
mois qui nous dira le moment qui est le
bon et le choix des Ukrainiens
une fois qu'on a dit ça je continuerai
en effet à parler aux présidents Poutine
et d'ailleurs on s'en entretenu ce matin
avec président Biden parce que nous
avons constamment essayé aussi d'éviter
des escalades et d'obtenir des choses
très concrètes et donc en particulier
j'aurai une discussion sur la question
de la sûreté et de la sécurité des
centrales nucléaires dans les zones
contestées en particulier cette deux
aporidia parce que je pense que le
travail que la France mène depuis
plusieurs mois et d'ailleurs depuis le
début du conflit rappelez-vous on l'a
fait dès le mois de mars sur la centrale
de Tchernobyl en soutien du très bon
travail fait par l'IEA et son directeur
général monsieur grossi est important
donc il faut continuer de faire cela et
d'engager donc nous continuerons voilà
merci beaucoup
voilà Renaud Girard nous venons
d'écouter Emmanuel Macron et Joe Biden
qui tenait donc une conférence de presse
commune allez on la débrie ensemble
quelques instants
étonnants non alors j'ai vu des copains
plus copains que ça non je sais pas moi
j'ai trouvé que sur la grande question
notamment du protectionnisme américain
j'ai trouvé qu'il avait finalement pas
eu d'accord et que ouais si si on a
discuté mais finalement chacun va faire
ce qu'il veut chez soi et tout le monde
sera content ou pas d'ailleurs
oui alors évidemment
les Américains se sont défendus ils ont
dû que c'était
tout ça pour dans le cas de la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique bien
Macron
a dit une chose assez simple à nous de
faire la même chose oui
maintenant on rappelle Renault peut-être
c'est important les Américains ont mis
en place un une flèche réduction actes
qui c'est en fait des subventions
énormes sur des produits américains
concernant la transition énergétique des
batteries des énergies ne renouvelables
les voitures électriques pour favoriser
l'économie américaine et ce qui est bien
défavorise l'économie européenne puisque
il n'est pas du tout
rentable pour un Américain d'acheter par
exemple une voiture européenne en face
d'une voiture américaine voilà donc il y
aura maintenant c'est effectivement
Emmanuel Macron a eu raison de le dire
libre aux Européens de faire la même
chose est-ce qu'ils vont y arriver
c'est pas sûr parce que les institutions
européennes
le Conseil des ministres ou même la
Commission ne montre pas non pas donné
des gaz d'une ilanimité d'efficacité
très grand c'est en dernier donc nous
allons nous verrons
il y a une chose intéressante que
Biden a dit c'est à dire que il
n'est pas revenu et
donc c'est la nouvelle position
américaine donc il y a pas de changement
de régime souhaité en Russie il est dit
il a dit qu'il était prêt baiden parler
avec Vladimir Poutine la nuit Poutine
mais dans le cadre ça c'est intéressant
dans le cadre de l'OTAN c'est ça il ira
pas tout seul il va pas court-circuiter
les autres quoi entre Moscou et
Washington
entre vous savez sur la sur la l'affaire
de la Syrie de l'usage par Bachar
el-Assad de d'armes chimiques contre la
rébellion en Syrie
il y avait eu
les Alliés ça veut dire qu'il fallait
faire quelque chose président Hollande
avait pratiquement fait chauffer les
rafales si vous voulez oui c'est ça et
on avait appris au dernier moment que le
ministre
russe des Affaires étrangères la broff
et le ministre rue américain The Voice
étrangère secrétaire d'État
Kery c'était entendu à Genève en fait
sans nous prévenir sans nous inviter à
la discussion et donc il y a une
discussion directe
pour sur cette affaire des armes
chimiques en Syrie là ce qui dit c'est
que si discutent avec Poutine il
considère que Poutine ne veut pas de
cette discussion
il
le fera avec les autres membres de
l'OTAN pas il ne va pas discuter sur le
dos des Polonais etc etc je oui Renaud
je donc on a c'était courant il y a eu
peu de questions finalement alors très
étonnant et ça j'aurais qu'on en parle
c'est pas tellement le fond c'est la
forme on a posé une question à Joe Biden
sur ce protectionnisme il a répondu je
suis très confiant pose c'était ma
réponse ça dure à peu près deux secondes
alors qu'Emmanuel Macron avait pris le
temps d'expliquer bon de peut-être noyer
le poisson en nous disant que les
discussions c'était très bien passées
pour finalement nous dire que
les Américains ne reculeraient pas et
qu'ils seront obligés de faire la même
chose sur ce protectionnisme économique
en Europe en revanche une question d'une
journaliste américaine sur la politique
intérieure bon une loi sur le rail
visiblement alors là il avait pris le
temps d'y répondre alors là ça montre
c'est très intéressant ça montre le
mépris incroyable des journalistes
américains
sur les relations
franco-américaines comme si c'était
vraiment des cadets de leur souci c'est
quelque chose de totalement accessoire
et que en revanche
les congés payés des ouvriers du rail
américain là c'était vraiment un sujet
qui pouvez pas attendre et donc il
fallait absolument quatre journalistes
quatre questions de journalistes
à Baden et effectivement Joe byday
n'aurait pu avoir la politesse de dire
écoutez madame je suis là avec mon ami
la République française les droits aux
vacances des ouvriers du rail américain
ne le concerne pas directement et donc
là dessus mais non il a répondu alors je
pense que il s'est aperçu de
la grossièreté de répondre à une telle
question devant délégation française
puisque à la fin il a dit
vous voyez maintenant ça permet de
montrer que
les États-Unis contrairement à l'Europe
n'ont pas de congés payés
transition pour essayer de faire passer
la pilule mais c'est écouter
c'est la réalité si vous voulez pour
la les Etats-Unis pour les journalistes
américains
la France c'est pas grand chose
je vous l'ai dit d'ailleurs avant dans
cette discussion qu'on a eu avant les
avant longue discussion puisque la
conférence de presse a eu 1h30 de retard
voir 1h président des Français qui a
vraiment été respecté par les Américains
parce qu'il leur tenue tête que
l'histoire lui a donné raison sur
beaucoup de sujets Vietnam c'est de
Gaulle c'est de gauche le reste Renault
ne compte pas vraiment je vous lis ce
que nous disent les gens sur Youtube
c'est marrant le premier commentaire je
me demande après la conférence de presse
là lorsqu'on a repris l'antenne Nelly
Octopussy je me demande qu'aurait donné
une rencontre Joe Biden et le général de
Gaulle Joe Biden de Gaulle dit jenkied
bon voilà
c'est rigolo que les gens fassent le
lien et pense à de Gaulle lorsqu'on
parle de
aucun journaliste américain ne se serait
permis de poser une telle question sur
les droits aux congés payés des ouvriers
du
rails américains dans une conférence de
presse devant le général de Gaulle je
crois que non je crois bien je n'ai eu
beaucoup de conférences de presse
beaucoup de déplacements de présidents
américains en France et réciproquement
personne n'a
osé poser une question là ça prouve à
quel point s'est passé dans les mœurs et
bien c'est pas grave les Français sont
là ils peuvent attendre et voilà et on
va parler
mais c'est il faut reconnaître que toute
cette affaire la question est
extrêmement grossière et c'est assez
grossier de la part de Biden je suis pas
sûr qu'ils sont ils sont soit perçus
d'avoir répondu à cette question allez
juste une dernière la question Renault
on a plus parlé des sous-marins pas une
seule question il en ont même pas fait
allusion eux j'ai l'impression ou
peut-être en sous-entendu mais même pas
quelque chose sur la dopacifique la
France sera associée etc à la sécurité
de la dopacifique mais les réalités sont
connues
et en direct en famille c'est terminé
voilà puis c'est pas la peine de les
ressortir dans la mesure où tout le
monde sait que effectivement dans la
lope Pacifique l'influence de la France
par rapport à l'influence américaine
c'est un un contre 100 quoi merci
infiniment Renaud Girard merci vous avez
tenu un marathon on vous a dit vous
inquiétez pas vous venez un petit quart
d'heure avant un petit quart d'heure
après puis on en parle plus et bien ça a
duré plus de deux heures parce que plus
de 2h30 même parce que les deux présents
ont eu beaucoup de retard merci de nous
avoir suivi sur le Figaro.fr sur Youtube
revenez quand vous voulez Renaud vous
avez dit bon maintenant j'ai un joker je
suis pas obligé de revenir tout de suite
mais je sais que vous adorez ça et merci
de nous éclairer à chaque fois
je salue rien de Becky évidemment il est
en régie lui aussi il a passé du temps
je salue Anna André germer qui était à
la traduction merci à elle et puis je
vous laisse sur le figurant là il vous
reste avec nous parce que il y a le
Figaro idée là qui vient de débuter il y
a à peine 10 minutes à l'Infinity le
crawl peut être invité il faudra
évidemment pas ça excellente soirée sur
le figure live